the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the energy was electric at tip off for
round five of the sinkfield cup here in
st louis sparks flew across the boards
and underdogs flourished co-leader
maxine bashir lagrav hoped for an easy
layup but was dunked on by linear
dominguez jumping him to the top of the
standings the all-star matchup of wesley
soh and fabiano carawana fizzled as both
players shot their shot but had to
settle for a draw with three points
apiece the leaders hoped to rebound and
create some separation going into the
rest day
round five of scintillating chess coming
up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the 2021 sink fill cup here in st
louis there are many famous parks where
the players can go to for rest and
relaxation but as we hit the midpoint of
this crucial event there will be no time
to relax as the players will have to
bring their a-game if they're going to
try to make a move and win the
tournament to call all the action we're
going to jump to the studio with
alejandro and yasser
st louis welcomes 10 of the top players
in the world to participate in its
marquee tournament the strongest event
held in american soil it's the sinfield
cup the last leg of the 2021 grand chess
tour and it has been a thrilling
thrilling tournament to call all of the
action i'm grand master alejandro
ramirez here with grand master yes sir
sarah one alejandra a pleasure as always
calling the action with you and maurice
especially for the
last two rounds has been
remarkable usually we have a good time
no matter what is going on on the board
yasser but wow
the players have not given us any
respite it's been action after action
absolutely hello everyone and welcome to
our live coverage of round five of the
2021 sinkfield cup as mentioned the last
two rounds have been some of the most
memorable
chess rounds i've ever commentated on
and i've just
whoo
let's hope it continues after four
rounds what are the standings alejandro
it was a victory one of the four
victories yesterday that's catapulted
linear dominguez over maxima shirley
grav to join fellow teammates olympic
teammates fabiano carona and wesley so
at the top of the leader standings you
can see them there three out of four
points maxime himself still on plus one
is the chasing pack
fifty percent we have shakira mamadiarov
and richard report below them jeffrey
sean and sam shankland on minus one and
a much
much needed win for my student darius
schwiertz who scores one out of four so
far what an epic epic game it was uh
congratulations to him life is so much
better after a victory won our format
it's a ten player round robin and we're
back to classical chess 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves 30 minutes for the
rest of the game and a 30 second
increment all throughout absolutely no
draw offers in this tournament we've had
games where they have to draw by
eliminating every single piece off the
board except for the kings of course
and traditional scoring system one point
for a win half for a draw zero points
for a loss our most lucrative
price fund uh played on american soil
325 thousand dollars up for grabs
amongst these 10 players and our
schedule alejandro simple enough one
round a day except for tomorrow the
players have that well in their minds
tomorrow will be their first and only
rest day of this event surely they're
gonna take advantage of that and we
continue after that very simple one
round a day until the 26th if there is
the need to have a playoff not for the
tournament but for the grand chess tour
standings then we will have those
on the 27th of august with so many
decisive games i don't see how we're
gonna get into any kinds of playoffs uh
but i all i say is fingers crossed let's
keep it up and speaking of decisive
games we've had a huge amount in this
tournament to take a look at how that
stands up against other events we have
grand master maurice ashley oh thank you
alejandro indeed when you see classical
chess you usually think it's going to be
slow lots of draws at the high level not
like rapid and blitz but not in this
event with his which has been slash and
burn chess
brutal knockouts and some candidates for
brilliancies starting with round one we
had three out of five games we thought
this would be an anomaly these kind of
brilliant hits
round two ah more like what we're used
to one out of five decisive games plenty
of draws but round three said uh-uh back
to the bloody fighting chess that this
tournament seems to be staking out and
round four it was more of the same four
out of five decisive games our edge are
spinning with all these amazing moves
brilliant shots 12 out of 20 decisive
games that's 60 percent
that is completely unusual for a
tournament of this level this caliber we
just go back a few months to the first
tournament on the grand chess tour for
2021
nine decisive games in nine rounds in
the super bet event that was held at
bucharest that's 20 out of those 45
games 20 decisive rate
we could go back to the last field cup
that was played in 2019
12 decisive games that's what we have
right now but that was done in 11 rounds
66 games 18 we got 12 already what kind
of numbers is this tournament putting up
in the last 20 years if you go to elite
players over 2600 the average draw rate
is 53 percent it's much lower for over
27.50
like these players like many of these
players in this event the current draw
rate for this tournament is 40
this is just absolutely a wild crazy
affair guys can we keep this up it's
been so exciting so thrilling
i expect to see more
contentiousness blood on the board
wonderful for me
i think that i can go an entire
tournament wishing for a round three
like we had here at the same field cup
but then round four came and said wait a
second you get another one wow can we do
it again as we see sam shanklin sporting
some of the cubitique uh swag that's
available there he's got the rapid and
blitz
uh blazer and if you want to match with
samsung qboutique stl.com we'll have
specials for you later today but let's
take a look at the pairings for round
number five the day before the rest day
shakuya mamedyarov with white will be
trying to catch linear dominguez who is
on a roll in this tournament he has
three points and a commanding way he did
it yesterday defeating maxine
vasherlagraf petersville will be playing
against sam shanklin the eight-time
russian champion unable to find his form
then a huge one for the standings wesley
so will be playing against richard
rapport rockford surging back after he
lost to mamadirov defeating peters
fiddler but wesley he knows that his job
is to get third place in this event and
clinch that grand chess tour title mvl
will try to come back for his loss
against darius fjords but the young man
just won his game yes he did and jeffrey
just lost his game is up against pavi uh
and with the white pieces that's okay
but after a loss you get fabby that's
not much of a reward let's talk about
the rewards uh what are they playing for
alejandro 90 000
is the first price of this tournament
and don't forget uh gran chester
participants are looking at those points
13 if you win the event out right only
eight is what wesley so needs and he's
looking at a third place price saying
eight of those points they get me an
extra one hundred thousand dollars for
the grand chess tour title and of course
all the prestige that comes with it
exactly fifty thousand in bonus money
for second twenty five thousand bonus
money per third mvl and fabi and shakri
are all looking at that bonus money that
handsome prizes throughout as we have a
picture of their intricate picture of
jeffrey jeffrey zhang at the board it's
got the filter on the camera so you get
that foggy look i think they're actually
looking through a star like a glass huh
i was thinking it might have been a mess
look at the mystery they're looking
through
an etched doorway i think yeah
nice by the way here at the saint louis
chess club and scholastic center in the
central west end uh is undergoing
massive
renovations and when they are completed
towards the end of this year the start
of next year it this is going to be an
absolutely beautiful facility it already
is but it's expanding
uh 200 percent i want to say probably
even more it's an amazing amount of work
that's going on you'll i think you'll be
thrilled to see the new playing halls
the new studio we're going to be
thrilled about the studio yes indeed and
there you have a picture of richard
rapport now richard yesterday
he played
a really nice attacking game and against
peter svidler essentially just kind of
bullied him off the board i want to say
peter has been having a real
harsh
time of it as we see the players
starting but i was starting to speed her
about that game yesterday yes he simply
said her brain missed firings he had a
plan
and he didn't follow up he followed
through with it his original idea was
not to take on g4 just leave that pawn
alone right solidify his position
maintain that tension and that was the
idea and he decided last minute take the
pawn what could happen and well what
happened was f4 f5 came storming down
the board
and ended up checkmating as king we
should point out that
there are just a few players responsible
for a lot of the decisive games in the
event peter is responsible for three of
them three losses to him and derek
with again three losses for him so that
and they didn't play each other so
that's seven decisive games between two
players then you had salmon there who's
been involved in three decisive games
himself with two losses
and a win so three players
already account for many of the decisive
games here and that's part of the thing
about the unevenness of the field right
we have players who are world world
championship candidate and fabiano
caruana we see here we have youngsters
like jeffrey zhang who are trying to
make a name for themselves we have
darius who's lower rated than most and
they're going he's going to be hunted by
everybody you could trust maximize after
him right now maxim is thinking i lost
yesterday you're a point you're you're
fish food like i gotta kill you
you can expect that maxine will play to
the very last pawn trying to prove
something here as he tries to bounce
back in this event
there have been a number of games uh
guys and jump in please the number of
games that have been played in this
tournament that i want to describe is
simply perfect that is to say
the winner
of those games there's absolutely
nothing i could criticize for example
lanier's win yesterday against mvl
lanier played perfectly every move from
rook d2 and queenie one and rook h6 but
it was fantastic he actually played a
perfect game against dardik as well
on round one right and then i'm thinking
about derek's loss to wesley where
wesley plays the black side of berlin
and essentially
makes no
not only did he not make a bad move he
didn't even make a dubious move or a
questionable one no every move was great
the the level
i don't want to say perfection the the
quality of the chess so some of these
games have been off the chart it's
simply perfect yeah games
well wow
a game that seems like it will not win
the brilliancy
already
yeah
is this game between wesley and richard
now we do know that wesley
with third place locks up the tournament
just right locks up the grandchild story
he doesn't win the tournament but he
locks up the grand chess tour and the
100 000 bonus that 100k starts to loom
really large in your mind the closer and
closer you get so wesley it's got it's
got to be very difficult to catch him
the pursuer by the way third place is
what he needs if chakriar who's
currently at fifty percent with wesley
sitting at plus two if shakhtar
overtakes him and wesley falls back
to fourth place
that's a tall tall order in this
tournament is only five rounds left
wesley will literally have to go through
a full-scale collapse for that to happen
so it's almost over the granchester
title sad to say it's almost done after
these first four rounds let's just be
real
but the jockeying for second and third
rocking for second and third is wrong
but the point i'm making about right now
is a nice grand chest to her pen i gotta
go upstairs and get me one of those
you guys got paint we got beds i don't
have a pancetta
baby
yeah yeah baby the cool kids got
something
what i'm talking about right thank
goodness for that
anyway yes uh
wesley knows full well that if he
just keeps stays cool
and doesn't do anything crazy he may not
win the same field cup with that
attitude maybe
but he will definitely win the tour
and so we'll keep an eye on us to his
attitude and the positions he's playing
uh unless you know he comes up with some
brilliant crazy idea in this position
which i think
most of us feel like is dry dry dry as
ever but i wanted to bring your
attention to one game where peter
decided to play an unusual fifth move
let's call it that a lot of moves
there's so many fifth moves here it's
ridiculous i mean bishop g5 was the main
line bishop e2 was employed bishop e3
was the main line for a while fischer
like bishop to c4
then his pawn pushes like g3 you could
even throw an f4 if you want then they
started playing a four eight somebody
who played bishop d2 i think that was
one four is the young bun forest yeah
before he's played that
remember remember the move h4 by ray
robson and then wesley
yeah naraditsky and the like play that
right well i saw b3 recently b3 as well
f3 of course you can play every well why
not play bishop d3 is what peter played
today certainly not a square that the
bishop will appear at often i would put
this probably around the five percent
level uh oh no much lower much lower
right yeah i agree it's got to be sub
five percent right because of all the
other lines but bishop d3 blocking the
defense of this piece
and reinforcing this pawn but the bishop
doesn't look like a great piece on the
square sam played e5 after not too much
thought chasing the knight away and put
his bishop on e6 castles and knight c6
saying i've got
good squares for my pieces and you don't
have control over the d5 square so at
some moment the move d5 is always going
to be threatened to just open up the
game for black and he's going to have
free play so white's going to have to be
careful let's see what peter has in his
mind to stop the very strategically
desirable
as his p setup is not really made to
contain black's forces yeah it's fashion
all over again why do people choose
different things bishop d3 is hot hot
fashion at the moment you've seen it
play over the last year several times
wow and for some reason people are
seriously looking at it like bishop d3
the logic is pretty simple
h3 is a huge variation of the night or
right people play e5 and your knight
usually retreats back to e2 people
decided okay is the bishop on d3 really
so bad
that
i can't put it there and develop it
quickly instead of keeping it on f1
uh the answer well we don't really know
still jury's still out white usually
plays for a very quick f4 there are
other ideas in the position but you'll
see an f4
relatively soon f4 looks very compelling
after all this bishop on d3 can be a
target for black pieces whether it be
with knight before or something dropping
on c4 so the move f4 you know you get to
play f5 and as as we were talking about
there's a strategical strategic battle
for control over the t5 square i would i
would expect f4 to be a natural
follow-up by the way uh
is this
line theoretical do people play this
stuff alejandro bishop c5 jack
there's still very very very few games
there's saying that something's
theoretical here would be
an exaggeration okay people are just
trying to play it and see how it goes
but okay very very rare at the moment
all right well keep an eye on that the
game actually that caught my attention
because i play it a lot
well these days is blitz but certainly
um
this whole knight f3 g3 approach
and
i know that fabi funnily enough he
actually likes the benoni from both
sides i think he prefers to the the
space that the bononi brings and after
them of bishop g2 e6 my students call
knight f3 g3 bishop g2 the midlife
crisis opening the middle like
it's sort of like when you don't have
time to start
just knowing
every game
exactly and it's sort of like e7 e6 it's
kind of an invitation
for white to play c4 d5 d4 and kind of a
benoni reverse where well you've already
committed your pawn to e6 and stuff like
that um
but i like the approach that
uh
uh
jeffrey has taken as well which
is not so much as an invitation to to
have a reverse grunfeld but something
like after for example knight c6 c4
we have all of these transpositions in
chess and you can end up in a catalan
and i used to play this black side of
this catalan i don't know if this ever
became popular in your practice i'm
black
takes
queen a4
takes
knight takes d4 queen takes d4
bishop takes c6 and i like sacrificing
my my queen
as black
bishop d7 rook d1
today i actually did look at this line
with it with an engine and it really
does favor white greatly but at the time
that i was playing this stuff it was a
lot of fun i've got this really great
light squared bishop i do have a pawn as
well as a bishop and a rook for the
queen and
it's funny if you're not
careful with white
[Laughter]
h5h4 might surprise you veronica it's so
fun for a blitz game oh it is it is and
again uh we we went from the old man's
crisis uh opening to
a uh reverse grunfell to a
catalan and these transpositions after
the move d4 we've seen instead to avoid
that catalan position we've actually
seen fabi capture on d4 knight takes d4
and again to avoid let's say
patterns of a reverse grunfeld like that
might appear like this we see e
five on the board and i'm assuming
knight b3 is an automatic here for white
no not f3 is also a move knight f3 is
also yeah
wow it's not main line but it's not
automatic 93 certainly yeah that's 93
several in the main line because after
knight f3 knight
c6
i've always thought of the gruenfeld as
you you've purposefully played the move
d4 to open the bishop
as i said it's not the main line but the
line does continue c4 d4 e3 there's
there's been some theoretical analysis
here i actually believe two of my
students play this in a tournament
against each other right these actually
look like old games of
uh paul carres he used to play uh these
things uh like a reverse terrace but
sorry
there's still some theory here black's
supposed to be okay sure but white's not
worse either so knight f3 is a
completely playable move as you said
though knight b3 is certainly the main
line of the position sure
and again from
my
practice the idea of a groomfeld is
really to kind of open up this bishop
very early and put pressure on the t5
pawn pressure
will be exerted both by bishop to g5 as
well as knight to c3 let's keep an eye
on this game and uh maurice uh have you
been drilling down on uh peter's
approach to the night or
yes i have and let me just pull this
position up this is very unusual
position let's say not popular uh
at least the way they played it i hear
you alejandra what you're saying
recently but the online database shows
that after this position knight e2
bishop to e6 i should point out bishop
to d3 is has featured in thousands of
games about 4 000 games wow by
comparison
the move bishop g5 is more like 84 000
games so and and then another move
bishop e3 also in the 80 000 plus so
this move by comparison rare e5 is the
most popular move in this position sam
played it pretty much instantly knight d
e2 also popular with bishop to e6 136
times is featured and then castles and
now
here most popular is bishop to e7 not
putting the knight on c6 right away this
only appears 96 eight times bishop e7 47
times
getting prepared to castle get the
bishop here one of the points is that
sometimes your knight wants to be on d7
to be able to hold up this knight
so you can replace it if there's ever a
bishop g5 but he played knight c6 and
peter instantly played f4
i only found two games in the database
from this position
two wow
which is quite unusual
he takes f4
knight takes that four knot bishop takes
which may later run into a queen b6
check and your pawn on b2 is hanging and
knight to e5 and there's only one stem
game hiberla galewski
i think it's a polish player
not the top of the rating scale this
position and sam has played every move
instantly just bing bing bing bing
banging down his moves to this position
peter has played
a4
which was not played in the stem game
king h1 was at this moment so sam now if
he had prepared this
using the stem game he's seeing this
move for the very first time a4 of
course
in chess sooner or later
your opponent is going to play a move
you have never seen right and you're
you're going to be tasked with
solving what to do after that a lot of
people prepare openings thinking that
somehow that preparation
will carry them through the whole game
that's not chess that's not realistic
you're going to be forced to think and
look at sam pulling up his chair saying
it's okay
by the way i love this shot a shout out
whoever's upstairs without that's kevin
kevin duggan with this shot it's just
beautiful look at that focus of sam
shanklin
maurice i hear you loud and clear at
some point
you can study all you want but you will
be faced positions that even though you
study you will be challenged new ideas
different move orders a different plan
you hadn't considered a blunder your
opponent could blunder and you might not
have considered it
in your calculations maybe it was a
difficult refutation right but you have
to do it over the board a second or
third choice and the engine you're using
won't show it that show the move your
opponent just played as one of the top
two three four or five blues right it
just plays some move that the engine's
like what well that's not what we're
thinking about you'll say well the
engine didn't say this move good good
luck with that we've got to solve it
right now at the border there's sam he
wants to looks like he was ready to play
but he's a tad nervous he will be
allowing this pawn on a4 to go to
potentially go to a5 he'll have to judge
whether or not that's okay for him uh
whether or not that pawn on a5 is is
going to be a
plus for white or a weakness is it can
be attacked by knight c6
if if black chooses to go back with the
knight
iniesta niri getty's hesitating so a
well prepared player hyper well prepared
i always want to point this out for the
fans
not to beat yourself up because players
at the highest level hesitate over their
moves as well you see it live
the challenge that they face is very
similar to the challenge you face they
might know a little bit more than you do
but still it is never easy to play this
game nice and
sam's reach about to reach for his
bishop uh just turning our attention uh
for a moment to the shackriar
versus lanier dominguez game now again
lots of points
between the two players in this game
were near tie for first shaq coming off
of
really really painful loss i wanted to
say
against the wild card sam shanklin that
really dented his ambitions and we
already have a result what
wesley so and richard report have found
a way to repeat
what
well that's what i was worried about
that's what i was saying but that is
wesley so he is the type of person that
says this is my lead in the tournament
right i'm playing one of the higher
rated players
i'm white
let me force a draw
i don't want to burn any bridges here
he's guaranteeing himself the grand
chess tour he sees the bigger picture i
mean and he's saying that we'll we'll
bring him down here to hear his thoughts
but that's my guess yeah
that's his first impression and i think
it's easy to criticize players that do
this especially with white but when
you're basically guaranteeing yourself a
hundred thousand dollars by doing this
yeah you just have to say well yeah
that's what the tournament says this is
what you need to do right right this
tournament is not a tournament in
isolation that's the point yeah right
the big picture is he has to do well in
the super bet in in bucharest he did one
uh paris right fantastic he did well
here enough in the saint louis rapids
fourth is not bad
yeah and now he's saying all i need to
do is come in third guaranteed so he's
seeing the bigger picture this will be a
tour title his second one only magnus i
think have repeated as defeated ever to
be a winner on the tour so he'll say
i've got two titles just like magnus
nobody else has done it so
that is gotta be the way he thinks at
least that's the way we think he's
thinking but we'll put him in the hot
seat nevertheless and
his thoughts well i'm just thinking
about these olympics where you have
these uh qualifying heats and here's
what it's all about the grand chess tour
itself uh five legs wesley sow
got this very nice commanding lead says
i've got to come in here clinch
third
and he's doing it for their job
and remember it's clinch third right if
mvl
no or shock wins only only
mvl he gets fourth and he gets it so
right chakras actually
yeah no this is uh now what can you say
i i i say well done i'm saying i
expected the other bird
you know
just to show the game uh however brief
it was it was a berlin and it's the one
with rookie one and bishop f1 richard
played knight f5 c2
as wesley seeks to just play the move d4
taking
territory in the center we saw a trade
of knights on e5
kick that rook backwards d4 d5 bishop f4
the ship d6 wesley says queen f3 i'm
willing to trade bishops on my terms
you've got to
develop my queen next turn i'm going to
play knight d2
richard says i'm going to attack your
queen and this is
the repetition
and the players agree to a draw after a
few more repetitions and speaking of the
players here he is with us wesley saw
with maurice ashley
currently leading the tournament more
importantly leading the grand chess tour
is wesley seoul with us
wesley this this was a quick draw on
your part uh usually players say well
you've got the white pieces you're going
to go for it explain to us your
rationale yeah it's my responsibility i
mean first i'd like to apologize to
people also organizers
also the fans uh for the quick draw i
mean it's disappointing of course but
as a professional player
i kind of have to make decisions which i
think are correct and actually i'm not
thinking about the tour points or the
tournament standings and not one bit
it's just
uh i i'm not feeling very well today uh
i didn't sleep well last night i think
i've been drinking too much coffee
so i i gotta i gotta minimize my coffee
intake on that so i wasn't feeling the
best spirits
and there's sometimes
richard is a very dangerous player he's
very strong uh he stopped almost in the
top in the world so there's always in
the back my mind saying
just
be careful this game
um also
i've had history in the past before
where in the back of my mind i wanted to
play carefully like for example against
the pumice two years ago in the sinkhole
cup i wanted to play carefully with
white
and i wanted to make a draw at some
point but during the game i was
hesitating i got better position i
didn't know whether play for win
uh or play four door and then i lose i
lost that game so badly so i think
as a rule if you want to do something
you cannot you can't hesitate you just
need to do it so
yeah again like to apologize i it's not
my proudest moment but as a professional
i sometimes have to make decisions like
this and again i'm not thinking the tour
points
also against the berlin i think quite a
several ideas that could be playable for
a slight edge but then the game could
get long and if i made blenders things
could go bad
so so again not my proudest moment but i
take full responsibility we understand
you don't feel well why all the coffee
what's up with that
yeah it's my favorite drink yeah
i used to drink every day at home but uh
but yeah i this my third term in a row
so there's a lot of nervous tension also
in in between games between rounds also
i'm i'm preparing and sometimes feel
like it's good to have a hot drink by my
side but i just need to lessen the
caffeine a little bit so because
yesterday i drank coffee at
nine in the evening
and then i started lying in bed for for
the next 10 hours and i could barely
sleep wow that's a big mistake but
again
yeah obviously it's quite
it's uh not attractive to to go for draw
with the white pieces but uh
i i play tons of games every year and
sometimes you
get some bad games but but i was also
happy to save the game yesterday against
fabiano that's also one of the reasons
why i took the quick quick throw today
because yesterday could have gone badly
if fabian played a bit better
let's talk about that that game i mean
it certainly certainly was a difficult
one
uh when you you walked out of there
feeling feeling like this this was a
a good save
yeah i i think it was a very good save i
think
i wasn't expecting fabian to play 154
and i think he didn't get much out of
the opening but i also messed things up
and uh in fact yesterday was very nice
when he played a3
uh we bought miss after bishop takes a3
i just trusted him that he has knight b5
dropping my queen but then i miss this
a6 bishop a5 bishop b4 check id which
suddenly black is better
uh anyway fabiano is is a great
practical player so he's number two in
the world i think yesterday
i was doing very
very well but then he always keep keep
finding these practical chances and
objectively i'm fine but practically
it's not so easy to defend and uh
i made some mistakes and i was quite
fortunate actually that he played b4 in
the end game if he played bishop e3 he
could have some real chances but i was
quite confident my chances of holding
this opposite color bishop end game
but fabian as i said is very practical
so he just poses
problems
on his opponents problems are not
supposed to be there
your thoughts about how
crazy this tournament has been in terms
of all the decisive games we just never
see this at the sing phil cup or usually
on the tour in big events
yeah yeah that's true uh not classical
anyway classic yeah that's true well
there are some clearly out of form
players here like swirks and peter
and everyone wants to get a point from
those guys
so i i think
that's
that's one of the reasons for example if
you look at other tournaments like
norway chess if like argentari had a lot
of losses
last year also john big hammer had lost
previous year when you have one who's
clearly lower rated everyone tries to
get a point of them
but also two years ago the thinkful cup
was much stronger with average rating
2782
so
um
you want to play for win with white but
at the same time you don't want to
overextend
uh
you're playing a fine balance of uh of
playing for a win at the same time not
making a blunder
uh
and
yeah i must say peter spidler is clearly
out of form
and also we have some fighting players
like sam shankland and jeffrey shone
would you would you say that somehow
the the tour should try to include
players of like diverse levels so that
we can see this kind of fighting chess
and you guys will be able to go for it
more or do you want to stick with the
old formula of elite players all the
time
uh personally i like elite elite players
because their
ratings are there for a reason i think
if you invite the top 10 players in the
world i think that's what gives
the most excitement maybe change the
format a little bit maybe don't blame
players but basically the format
because for instance stay more rajib
makes draws but his rating is very high
he won't be in the top 12 in the world
if he's not a good player so i i think
granchester has tried inviting uh new
players like like bador jabava or ivan
sarik
in the past but they haven't really been
able to compete for the top prizes so i
think
reading he's going to defend my boy
sarge there he he got second in the
tournament very recently it was his
worst half that kind of rule
i
you're right i forgot about that
combination
yeah i have to thank gary for for that
yeah you become second and then you end
up laughing that's right
gary had a poor tournament yeah that's
through yeah if i'm afraid i think
ratings are there for
for for a reason you said change the
format what format would you suggest
that could make for more contentious
chess because when you say excitement
the fans like to see wins they want yeah
they'd like to see decisive games and
and this tournament has 12 decisive
games two years ago 12 sizes games in
four rounds two years ago it was 12
decisive games in the entire tournament
11 rounds exactly
yeah maybe
yeah jeff
is very
objectively drawn these days engine
always keeps point zero zero maybe
change format like gives slightly more
points for the wins or or you have
another you make the time control
shorter and then if players draw then
they have to play again
in in a shorter time control i think
that's uh
that's what's necessary you would feel
okay with that oh i'd love to yeah i
played in play norway armageddon i also
like rapping with
i i think i i love the i'm still quite
young so i
i can
adjust and i can play faster faster
chess but there might be other
uh suggestions also but i think the
format may be easier okay we'll put your
suggestion in the ballot box yeah i'd
have or yeah or
yeah there are other extreme formats
like you can't play certain openings or
no castling but that's a bit too extreme
but yeah okay well
uh good luck in the rest of your games
and stay away from so much coffee yeah
that's true now i was thinking now i get
two two rest days and i'm going to rest
and get some sleep and try to come back
and and play some fighting chess where
you got a lot of exciting shits coming
do you look forward to it two quick two
quick questions for you wesley the first
is that i really liked
the norway chess format when they
experimented with the armageddons i
enjoyed it as a chess fan tremendously
uh
again your your thoughts
if the uh syncfill cup or
the classical chess events of the grand
chess tour was to use that format would
you
find that
uh
acceptable yeah i'm completely open to
it just because um i also don't like
these these drawers and if you're going
to stick to this format you're with all
the best players they're inevitably
going to have love draws like london one
year for example right so i think uh
even if you don't make the game
immediately armageddon but you can just
shorten the time control so if you draw
in a 90 minute game maybe you can move
the 30 minutes and so on after move 40
then you can play rapid
blitz yeah
with the same colors yeah or i think
that would
make much sense or maybe you can give
slightly more points to the wins like
two two and a half you know and then one
fourth draw or got it because you had
such an easy rest day we're going to put
you to
work as a commentator i know you love it
i just want to turn your attention
uh if you don't mind to the game of
fabiano and uh jeffrey because this is a
kind of a funny grunfeld defense
a position but with colors reversed
and i wanted to i wanted to ask you
uh
is is fabi
over extended himself he just played the
move a5 bishop g5 and i've never seen a5
before me me either
why i wanted to
i wanted to
to
tease you
with a4 bishop e6 and as a grunfeld
defense player uh
what's your what what are your thoughts
at first sight looks like
black's just losing a bun yeah like
knight city or three
knight c3 yeah maybe not knight 34.
and knight before the purpose here of
course is that this pawn
uh now that the pawn's on a4 already you
don't trap the bishop right yeah and
then place bishop e7 bishop f6
but maybe this is fine for black so
maybe not knight c3
but maybe i can play after bishop e6 i
can't play c4 right they take c4
should i take this trade the question
the queens
first and bishop b7 right this looks
nice for white
doesn't it
but actually after c4 i think fabi will
play d4 yeah he for sure because he
wants to keep all the pieces and play
four wins so we'll play d4 well this is
the
three the the risk taking
that you talked about is white i mean
okay jeffrey's not the highest rated
player yeah but he's quite capable if
you give him a winning position he's
gonna beat you yeah definitely now jeff
is very dangerous i think everyone is
capable
uh so that that's what i mean you you
have to take a fine line between taking
risks and playing solid because you
don't want to lose it white but same
time i've never seen a5 before but as i
said fabi plays for win with both colors
right
so this could backfire but he just wants
to keep the game
going so that's why i played e4 today
because
then you you know exactly what your
opponent wants
right yeah um
i thought black was fine
with knives except a5 but
it's going to be a tough fight now yeah
uh wesley uh congratulations thus far on
your grand chest store results certainly
uh you're leading for a reason well done
and get your rest we'll see you on the
other side of the rest day there are
only four players
right
all right it's nice i mean
magnus is not here this year so
and also ding
we're missing some crocodiles that's for
sure all right thank you wesley and what
do you have uh what have you been
keeping your eye uh i see you've got a
position on your board i've been told
that rex sinfield has gone around the
central west end buying up every coffee
shop
shutting it down shutting them all down
shutting them all down nice in the
central west end
you're going to have the difficulties
grabbing your coffees
let's take a look at the peters miller
neither with sam shanklin
we have a few moves in that position and
i have to say we thought sam was
reaching for that bishop it wasn't it
wasn't the bishop it was actually the
pawn
he prepares to fianchetto risky decision
i prefer it actually i like the pawn on
g6
not only because of the long
diagonal but you know with this pawn on
e4 sometimes these squares tend to get a
little bit well drafty and i don't think
the bishop is doing as much on e7 as it
is on g7 i like this decision and
especially because of the bishop on d3 i
didn't think it was gonna be so much
that you moved it out of the way but
because the bishop's on d3 certain
targets against uh d6 right
so if the bishop
and it will go to g7
opening up the half open d file to
target the pawn on d6 that still is
going to require quite a bit of
maneuvering on peter's part and after
bishop g7 we've caught up with the
players and again i see castles
i see rook c8 i see very very typical
um sicilian-like play for blackside i i
think
sam at exactly this moment although he's
not in the confessional booth uh will
will say i like my position it's it's
it's decent it's a sicilian position it
doesn't have the usual weaknesses and
especially it's not one of those razor
sharp double-edged i'm going after your
king you're going after mine right it's
more of a slow affair you have the
weakness on d6 you don't have that
counter play on the queen side as
strongly you still have it but
definitely not as strongly and
i would personally take black because i
just love playing the sicilian with the
black side right i don't like playing it
with white as much oh interesting and
but that's a personal choice i think a
lot of people would take this with white
right and for me i i didn't really
understand the move a2 a4a as maurice
was saying a2 a4 was a bit
i guess of a novelty and that was where
sam played g7 g6 uh to my way of
thinking and i a
really really simplified way of thinking
about this night or with the move b7 b5
i'm only terrified of the pawn going to
b5 when black is
ambitiously attacking the pawn on e4
he's thinking to play b4 or my kings on
the queen side
and or this bishop is going to b7 so
with the bishop already on e6 i don't
see b5
b4 as something i need to stop i don't
necessarily like my pawn on a5 actually
a4a5 doesn't do anything for me in my
mind
i'm thinking okay
to eggs
takes queenie one
i don't know bishop e7 again
other moves queen out castles and put my
king
well maybe maybe
i want to throw in queen h3 right so i'm
trying to target the spawn on e6 i'm not
saying that i have a big advantage or
anything like that
i just i'm just saying that i personally
don't see b5 b4
as a big deal and i'm going to move my
knight anyway my knight's not great on
c3 so i didn't understand the move a4
and after
we're just going to get up to date with
the players bishop d3 to e2 as well at
least
white's not walking out of here with a
big advantage or any kind of advantage
for that matter it doesn't seem like it
especially with the loss of a tempo with
the fact that black gets to fianchetto
instead of long fee and catering by that
i mean many times in this kind of
sicilians you castle you move the rook
out of the way the prediction
goes back to f8 and then g6 bishop g7
you have to wait to do all of this
because at the beginning of the game it
costs too many tempe to play g6 and
bishop g7 but here with a4 as you said
thrown in yeah sam says oh thank you for
the temple let me put the bishop on its
best diagonal i'll take advantage to do
precisely that and again a lot of dragon
players will be very very satisfied i
like this line for sam i think it's a
good opening choice absolutely uh
turning it over to you maurice what game
has caught your eye well you said you
liked the opening choice for sam i think
you're going to like the opening choice
for your student dariush looking very
good against maxime vashila grav as we
see here out of this joco piano knight
to e4 attacking knight back to d7 saying
i don't mind you getting the two bishops
as long as my knight is very active on
c5 we're going to see that knight visit
that square a little bit later bishop d5
bishop b6 knight to g3 attacking this
piece again the willingness to give up
the two bishops that's not something you
see frequently we say the advantage of
the two bishops but if you get dynamic
play
you could have your own chances and here
he says i'm trading so i can play f5 i
don't care about stinking pawn on c6 you
can have it what would happen by the way
f5 also which is even more obviously
dangerous what happens if white decides
i'm going to take this pawn
looks like a pawn
not so much knight to c5 hitting this
pawn twice
at the moment impossible to defend
directly and he's going to take and play
e4 and then tonight's going to be secure
forever if you try to play d4 saying
okay whatever you go ahead and take this
back i'm going to put a bishop on d3 and
my pieces are going to explode no thank
you let's park the knight on the d3
square hitting the rook and be careful
because if you decide well this knight
needs to be attacked then all of a
sudden
boom knight takes on f2
erupting in your position queen to h4
the threat of f4
unstoppable
exploiting this pin on the diagonal
suddenly black is just completely
dynamic and taking over the game so
back to here f5 trading on f3 f5 it
looks like darius has got a lot of
confidence suddenly and pushing his pawn
forward saying i i won my first game
the first three you know what i was
warming up i was warming up now it's
time for us to play chess and look at
maximum right now saying uh what this
guy's supposed to be easy
this is not what i signed up for it's
also nice and easy to have confidence
when you have had this exact position
two hours ago on your laptop oh very
nice
preparation very important
this is just the beginning
cool well we'll have a lot to look
forward to one of the things that i
really wanted to shout out to the
audience thank you so much one of the
reasons why our shows have been so
enjoyable and i'm not joking is you've
had some great questions for the grand
masters on panel and really keeping us
on your toes so you can send us tweets
and we have some too how do how do
people participate in our show first of
all ollie under use the hashtag sing
field cup those tweets will go straight
to international master kostya kabuski
he's sifting through the best questions
answering some of them himself and the
very best they come here to the studio
with us and let's take a look at our
first tweet of the day from andy lucas
in a tournament like this where
television cameras are keeping track of
every move why do the tournament rules
still require players to fill out score
sheets what happens if in time trouble
score sheets are completed incorrectly
those are excellent questions andy
sometimes we don't touch upon some of
the little details of chess especially
we have a lot of newcomers into our game
that are used to online formats right
exactly you play online why would you
ever score anything i mean you have the
computer doing it for you this is a
little bit of a combination of rules and
traditions legacies yeah legacies but
the scoresheets are actually
uh used in tournament play in case of a
dispute right a a written record if you
will of the moves keep in mind
some of the rules a three move
repetition
rule 50 move rule how do i know that i
have reached the time control the
question is a very good one and i do
expect
that as we uh do more and more camera
work and more more broadcast the the
need for score sheets will lessen so for
example in golf tournaments now all
of the
the the the golf uh holes are being
recorded but they still
fill out their scoresheets and i know
scorecards still have to sign it at the
end right and if you do it wrong you
will be disqualified right and one guy
did get the card wrong and got
disqualified yeah i didn't sign it at
the end just left right one guy did that
in the u.s championship here and got
disqualified yeah that was god guys
as we speak but i think that that that's
one of the things that you have to um
think about is the the
the three move repertoire repetition the
50 move rule
the time controls and so on um also i
wanted to say that when i found it
really really
marvelous was as a memorabilia keepsake
i have seen some of the old grand
masters uh score sheets absolutely and
they're really fantastic my absolute
favorite i don't have uh uh the the
personalized copy was from paul morphy
and he's amazing right and he wrote down
the move
like a sentence
pawn p-a-w-n
to
the king's
fourth house
so it was pawn to the king's fourth
house
and it was like what alejandro and it
was like this incredible
and it was
poetry the flowery uh thing
and
then he had one like i ordered this
whole score sheet this massive score
sheet he had one little one castles
oh castles
so if you look at my score sheets i have
e 45 knight of three knight c6 castles
i write out castles you write out
castles i write you yes no way yes of my
scoresheet so you could see them for the
last 30 years i write castles i thought
that stopped being a thing like a
hundred years ago i'm not kidding like i
thought it stopped being hey it's a
tradition i've kept you know
the oral history oh wow impressive for
us
that's a great question thanks for it's
memorabilia it's also rules remember in
chess as opposed to many other sports
arbiter intervention isn't really
encouraged you have appropriate
supervision but if there's dispute
between the players
the arbiter can't immediately take a
side they have to check the score sheet
and see what's going on before they make
a ruling for example in the 50 move rule
even if an arbiter is actively watching
the game they don't stop the game
immediately when the 50 move has been
reached they wait until move 75 before
arbiter intervention can be done and
of course the player can claim at any
point after mu 50 but the arbiter can't
intervene until 75.
jump in here with the scoresheets
maurice are you one of those chess grand
masters who keep your scare sheets or do
you throw them away
oh definitely keep them okay come on
there's a real history as a matter of
fact
uh there was a very important score
sheet for me when i made the grand
master title uh
big win for me against adrian negolescu
and i took that scoresheet and gave it
to my dearest friend in the world willie
johnson and
uh pop i talk about him on the show so
that you know stuff stuff like that is
is important history
in the making uh for sure and
i think yeah you want to keep your score
sheets it is a record
you look at them later you say wow these
are my games and you could look of
course you could look at them on a
database but it's just not the same it
doesn't have that that same feel
that same sense of history there was a
second part to that question what do the
players make mistakes when they're
writing down yeah incorrect it's they're
not penalized i mean in time pressure
it's like chicken scratch sometimes
usually they'll recognize that this is
not the most frequent setting
for
games to be played it's not like
tournaments all over the world have
cameras aimed at the players recording
every single one of their moves and if
if you want to go to the dispute dispute
dispute two of those cameras
yeah sure you could do that if something
happened like a touch move infraction or
something like that but usually all of
us
have grown up writing our moves down
because we're playing it on these
weekend tournaments uh club events
bundesliga you name it and this is what
you need to do because the tournament
organizers don't have cameras
to be able to say this is what happened
or digital boards that are recording all
those moves so it's just a simple part
of tradition let's just keep it going
when everybody has a camera on them
god forbid let's then have that day come
you know every tournament everywhere and
everything is digitized then maybe that
will happen that being said when it
comes to mistakes i have seen this
happen for a grand master
writes down all of his moves right
thinks time trouble is over time
controls controls on he sees 40 on his
scoresheet right but
he missed a couple of boxes right and
it's actually only move 39 right and
there is no other time control until
move 40. right sorry you lost the game
if you let your flag fall and that has
happened at the top level events right
yeah
uh
the worst case scenario
sorry the storytelling time uh the worst
case scenario i ever saw is
uh
two players uh louboutin
matulovich uh there's an arbiter and the
players have reached their time control
the the arbiter has kept the score as
well because there was some time
scrambled the arbiter
gives the envelope and say gentlemen
please seal your move done so
everybody's in agreement that time
control has been reached
and the players go away and of course
three people including the arbiter have
done exactly what you did or said an
extra box got filled out and the
journalist who is writing his column
says
guys i only have moved 39.
one of the players lost
made the same mistake i don't know what
it was about the score sheet they filled
up they overlooked the sponsors box or
something that's crazy i know it was
like really hilarious uh there was a
shall we say a
a nattering of teeth
nice maurice what do you have for us
please
well this game
is still on fire it looks like as
alejandro said still in preparation for
black how do we know
black started with 90 minutes on this
clock one hour and 30 minutes he's got
three minutes and 14 seconds more than
he started with because of that 30
second increment he's at 133 and 14
while mvl is under an hour on the clock
wow the moves proceeding very fast this
is uh not the position that's chakras
position but this one
after d much thought mvl decided here to
play d4 it took him about almost 10
minutes to do he said forget about all
those taking upon
and instantly like instantly and that's
the novelty came right at him and you're
saying this is a novelty alejandra you
know because you've been preparing this
player d4 played no move
yet for mvl again in deep thought he
knows his opponent is extremely well
prepared and now the question is how to
duck diverge play something he hasn't
seen don't fall into any trap this is a
super dangerous moment as darius is just
making move after move after move again
you can see the clock times there look
at mvl
and i don't know what he's writing down
now
looks like he's uncertain are you going
to make a move or not by the way the old
days
the forum was to write down your move
prior
to playing the move then you looked at
your move or you confirm it you made
your move today it's considered
note-taking and therefore illegal
correct right so what did he write down
you can write down your times
but i'm curious i wonder if we can get a
little zoom zoom zoom and
your wish mvl is one of those players
that writes down the times this is the
only type of note keeping allowed during
a chess game you can notate the amount
of time you have or took for a move and
you have to write it in the same box
that you wrote your move
i'm also one of those very careful
time takers i like to
remember when i replay the game why did
i think for five minutes here did that
that was a good time i i had a 15 minute
thank you here by the way
zoom out before we zoom out no note uh
i don't know what chris byrd would have
to to say if he had to read the french
version
of the letters as you see there c is for
uh cavalier for the knight the f for
t for la tour which is a rook foo was
bishop
and uh i don't see any
where's d for for damn there are 15.
that's a d oh there that's a d okay that
is
taking on f three there so he's
certainly going to take notation in
is mother tongue and remember fide rules
you can write in whichever language you
want as long as it's consistent exactly
i i always thought that was really funny
about nick deferme and nick defermina
top junior top player when we were both
growing up in the u.s championships
always did it in german
for the night i was like
he's american
american
writing in german i just liked it i
think
he studied german i guess i just want to
turn our attention to shakriar oh sorry
before you do that
he played 94. you saw him play 94 and
get up right
but as he got up darius came back and
played queen h4 instantly right yeah let
me go again
i wasn't kidding it was just the
beginning
with a guy still blitzing out moves i
better not make a mistake because he
knows the whole game so yes knight e4
queen h4 number one choice by the engine
clearly as as alejandro is saying
alejandra why don't you just tell us how
the game's gonna go just just tell us
the rest of the game yeah the way it's
going now is so predictable all these
moves that are being played at least for
you for us it's new
uh instead of asking alejandro was
knight e4 the best move according to the
chess engine oh 94 is definitely one of
the problems well
he had to move the night i was wondering
uh the
yeah well the other option knight h5 to
try to keep the e file open and maybe to
play for queen g4 attack but you're
saying knight e4 was
accepted very good
now let me turn our attention to the
game of shakriar and lanier dominguez
again this is a top top game because so
many points in it for the players and
lanier
obviously tied for first where did it
come from it came from a queen's gambit
accepted and
again this is a defense that fashion has
over the many many decades sometimes
it's been very popular sometimes it's
completely fallen out of fashion nobody
knows why
we talk a little bit about
the night off and
certain moments
where so many things have been tried
this is one of those moments i've seen
queen e2 i have seen b3 i've seen bishop
b3 i've seen bishop d3 knight c3 not
i've even seen the move e4 no no knight
c3 is a try now really yeah you try oh
jesus yeah yeah yeah it comes back but i
know what you mean like when i like e4
when i grew up with queen's gambit
accepted books they were they all said
the knight does not belong on c3 for
white and you can even encourage it to
go to c3 because it's so bad and
nowadays people are actually putting
that their own purpose exactly and i
completely feel you every single move
here has been tried wow and suddenly you
see a new one rookie one like what
like i don't i play uh the queen's
gambit uh
uh
accepted as black and
for me rookie one is new i'll just leave
it there after rookie one knight c6 and
bishop d3 now that move i know
in combination with rookie one less so
takes takes
bishop
e7 i
white's approach is very strange but
okay now we've transposed everything is
okay we're back into normal territory
until i see this move knight e5
um
that for me is rare because it is a
straight-up pawn sacrifice a gambit if
you will white gets great
development for his pieces he's about to
play rook d1 he's looking at bishop
takes f5
and i suspect there's a way of with
precise play
black gets to equalize but you have to
remember each and every move and i can
see rook ad1 bishop f5 on white's agenda
gentleman a good gambit what do you
think it's not the type of
gambit that as black i want to be
solving over the board right now i
immediately i immediately see so many
problems right
yeah the guys prepared this too that's
the other problem why is this crazy that
means that he's not worse well that
means he's he might be saying yeah you
know what there's a way you can equalize
but show me that besides you better show
it because i did prepare this i don't
want to see this i got to take your pawn
and then you're going to figure out how
to
and then you're going to force me to
solve how not to lose or not to get a
worse position right no i don't want to
see this position and my bishop was
sitting on b7 already
i wouldn't believe you at all right yeah
but like this with the bishop still on
c8 a real couple of d1 i don't even know
how you're down the pawn you have to
tell me i'm down apart from you oh yeah
isolated queen
i'm actually down a pawn in this right
right six to five good luck with that
now take this l because i'll put a rook
on d1 and come get you right this is uh
i'm seeing this doesn't look like fun
yeah like b5 the desirable b5 to put
your [ __ ] just timing is all wrong you
lose on the spot
rookie one had a purpose thank you very
much for that night fork what i'm
thinking is i'm not happy don't get me
wrong i don't know
all of those precise moves bishop d6
rook d1
queen c7 the reason i put my bishop on
d6 i just wanted to give myself a square
for my queen that i wasn't unhappy about
like borderline losing it doesn't it it
feels like bishop even a line like
bishop f5 pawn takes f5 rook takes d6
it's almost a miracle black doesn't fall
apart
probably the the the
another another move yeah that kind of
you know it scares me you know i just uh
with no development i really don't want
to get into a tactical slugfest
but to your point
alejandro which was bishop takes f5
rook takes now you're looking for a
cruncher
discovery do you have it though i can
get back some material with that for
sure six right and still
kind of wonder if you can finish your
development effectively i don't know i
just
i i feel like
it might be enough for black you might
just have the tempo needed but that's so
close but that's the thing
is that the computer will probably show
you a way that you you walk this
incredible narrow path and no deviations
allowed but if you play six seven eight
absolutely precise mode zero zero zero
congratulations you've got your drawing
while drawing
what happens here rookie five i want to
trick you rook you're looking fine we're
playing a little
loosey-goosey
black right yeah
just for fun
okay
okay here's my trick queen c4 knight d5
oh
he fell for my trick he just likes this
trick
it's a nice trick that's true i just
wanted to listen that was awesome
beautiful little check mate i mean you
don't see that every day uh
victory that being said if you don't go
queen c4 right
[Laughter]
why do i have to go back
man
not no no no no no no i can't think
no it's a lot more dangerous right where
should i have gotten probably from the
start maybe i should have gone to a
different square rookie five uh rocked
me yeah you're right and of course here
we're playing a little bit suspiciously
we probably should go purposefully
purposely to show the dangers of the
position bingo that's exactly right but
it's also not trivial to us how you're
going to develop all of your pieces it's
the checking to the queen in this kind
of positions where we would love to hide
it we would like to hide the queen in
some position where it's not going to
get harassed
but i don't see it but hold up hold up
checking
the queen
we should note something though let's
back up
in this position
bishop f4 uh
not was knight takes d4 bishop f4 knight
f5 right that's kind of a voluntary
retreat and they played quickly
right yeah queen c2 played after nine
minutes thought after all his other
moves were blitzed out knight to f5 came
uh by lanier and then shakriya stopped
and thought for nine minutes we always
want to track that time just the way you
see mvl
tracking the time in the game we track
the time because it tells a story to us
because we know when you play quickly
it's because you're confident you're
prepared you know what to do if you most
of the time anyway sometimes
accidents happen but
when you take some time it's because
you're not sure what the next move is
and quincy c2
it can be met by knight back to d4 like
i was just on d4 why is your queen on c2
you want to attack my queen with rook d1
what if i play knight to d4 what's your
best square for your queen i would
consider that a slight how do you put it
moral victory yes and my queen is better
on d2 than it was on d1 because i think
exactly except the engine gives queen d1
as the best move get out of here
and against knight f5
rook c1
is considered the right move here rook
c1 keeping a slight edge for white
despite being down a pawn and and asking
black what to do in this position you
mentioned b5 is not playable right uh
because of the take in knight c6 and
then the bishop hangs b5 is definitely
not playable queen f3 why do you need
your queen on this square when it can be
great on that square so what do you
actually do here
after rook to c1 what's your next move
and i'm going to tell you what the
engine says you're going to tell me
truly to leave the building
night h4 it's time for a break
guys
i mean what is that what is it
one you got to play knight
nobody is playing knight h4
but
first of all i don't even understand the
move i guess you're trying to knight on
g6 right but but right now after a guy
plays rook c1 you're gonna leave all
your pieces sitting here and play a move
like knight h4 but what else do you do
bishop d7 is the other developing move
which loses on the spot takes takes and
takes and now you can't take with your
queen because we trade and this bishop
is hanging and if you take with the
knight then knight d5 and you're getting
cr like
all over bishop c7 is coming you're just
your queen doesn't have any squares
you're going to get killed so what do
you play after rook c1
that looks like so that's what i'm
saying if this was preparation chakras
part
maybe he forgot rook c1 was the move
because now or maybe he just didn't even
think of knight five and he tried to
solve it with queen c2 but now knight d4
is best bet bring it back to d1 pretend
you want to draw and then shift and say
rook c1 your move you don't have any
really good booze knight h4 uh if if
lanier finds knight h4 then you
definitely check the pockets
but maurice you lost me at queen d2
which was 10 minutes ago which was like
why is the queen not even more purposely
well suited for the square well b5
happens rook b rook d1 rook to d1 by the
way black is already better in this
position according to the engine bishop
to b7 because you just returned the pawn
you don't just you don't you're not you
want this girl i don't want that one
about queen e3 queen h3 queen e3 queen
to e3 queen b6 ah queen b6
that's not hanging oh my god i hate
computers
i mean that's that's why that's why
we're here we're just just staying it's
incredible it's just blocking itself
spinning the knight on d4 right well it
was pinned already so you have to solve
the problem so now you move you're
prepared to play bishop c5 you can have
this pawn any time you like black will
be like yeah i'm good for you you're
giving away your light square bishop to
just get a pawn back that is not what
you signed up for when you sack this
pawn so that natural play just doesn't
work now it's important to note back
here however right after queen d1
that b5
is possible
but not playable because of bishop to e3
the main point is that c6 square is
hanging bishop to e3 now knight back to
f5 again queen is best on f3 no need to
have it on the d2 square or to see
hang out on this side
hit this rook you're in big trouble here
as a black as wise pieces have just
sprung to life there's no easy way to
develop for black so rook c1 is the move
what will chakra
well what will linear do after queen c2
because it's hard to put your knight
back on d4 after you just took it off of
d4 he's going to spend some time trying
to work this out sometime i mean we know
linear loves taking his time but do i
see 47 minutes left for him
you do and it's a long thing he played
knight f5 after with with 1 26 on his
clock so he was familiar with the
position so he's 39 minutes into a think
right now playing a move that he was
supposedly familiar with knight f5 39
minutes on his clock to to play knight
d4
after a 40-minute thing that's why he's
top time you know one of the things that
uh chess players love to do is who's the
greatest of all time imagine a peak
morphe versus a peak fisher versus a
peak magnus and you go yeah yeah yeah
but these were different generations
different tools and they go yeah well
imagine you took a morphe and you gave
him a chess engine and all the databases
so that he could come up
to speed with the top grand masters how
would they perform i see this kind of
analysis where morphe would come saying
well the queen is much better on d2 than
d1 he'd have to rethink everything he
ever thought about chess to catch up and
i think that would just be
hard to impossible i mean you know like
because we grew up with certain beliefs
and we cling to them even when they're
dead wrong let me go on record to say i
hate those debates i just hate them i
think they're so out of place
you don't compare people from different
generations in different parts i mean
they learn from each other that's great
you see the influence of players on each
other that's great but you're not going
to come here and tell me oh the cappa
blanca play better than carpet i mean
they're completely different chess
players i agree i always hated those
debates especially online they seem to
never ending never ends yeah
michael jordan
win the versus
who's the better center bill russell uh
versus uh shaq versus not versus shaq
will chamberlain real chamberlain at
least they play at the same time but
would shaq be able to
of course shaq would dominate if you
were back in that day as well and the
generation the arguments continue now
you got freakish centers in the league
uh including the greek freak when he
played the center position
guys who could watch handle come off the
floor those long euro steps spin around
and dunk on you in your face or make the
pass and you're seven feet tall
no the times change players change and
chest is the exact same way
and your your beliefs about chess though
the critical difference in chess is that
all the modern players have seen all the
past players games and they've sucked
all the marrow out of the
juice out of that the knowledge that
they've gotten and now because they have
all of that they've then created beyond
that so you're not just coming in and
preparing
you have to realize that chess actually
changed that it's a different game and
they've and they feel that the kids feel
it in their bones
the kinds of things you could do now
that's why defensive play today is
remarkable yeah it's the stuff
that you thought you can't take that
pawn and it's like right oh we could
take it trust me the computer has taught
me how to just take pawns like this and
it's not gonna work not that they've
analyzed it that they understand why
they could take that pawn and still save
the game when back in the day told those
sacrifices of tiles he'd be like yeah i
don't think i want to sack that piece
well this whole conversation that we've
had in the last few minutes is actually
almost part and parcel of a parkside
chat that we did uh before the
tournament to have something to share
with the viewers during a break
absolutely yes we're going to take a
small break here in the studio catch our
breath and analyze the games further but
we're going to leave you with a little
bit of a special as we went around the
parks of st louis talking about
different topics in the chess world
especially some recent
events in our world so take a look hope
you enjoy it and we'll be right back
[Music]
alejandro
what have you done
during this pandemic
well
i have to tell you the pandemic came
just such a huge shock right for
everybody for everybody and the chess
world was affected in many ways i have
to say some positive and some negative
of course as soon as the pandemic hit
everything was canceled right we had all
these plans the us championship was
about to come up in 2020 we had a lot of
team tournaments going on it was the pan
american
national championship pan ams are april
right actually pan ams are in december
and we qualified for the final four the
national championship that's what i
meant the national championships for the
universities in san luis university was
of course qualified ready to compete
with the best here
and suddenly
we just didn't have the ability to
travel
all over
all cancelled
wow that was a tough blow but luckily
for us in our sport we were able to move
it online okay very nice
we weren't able to manage to make the
final four online so that was cancelled
as well but slowly slowly we started
getting more tournaments and i'm happy
to say that missouri has two world
champions not only that st louis
university win the world university
blitz championship
but mizzou missouri university headed by
christian kirilla they want the rapid
protection
congratulations so
you guys ended up being world champions
right
so cool a tournament that had never been
hosted before because of the pandemic
video was well we can host it online
that makes it kind of easy nice very
nice the st louis university your
foreign students
they must have been terribly impacted in
all kinds of ways they had a tough
decision to make of course there were
lockdowns around the world and some of
them were unable to travel to america
okay
they weren't able to attend classes in
person
everything was moved online they had a
tough decision to make do you want to
take online classes from here or do you
want to do it from your home country and
some of them were just unable to travel
at all even if they had the desire to
come to america we had visa issues we
had closed borders it was just difficult
for them and i have to say it was a very
very tough first semester there with the
pandemic and slowly everything was moved
online we were able to get zoom meetings
we were able to move all of our classes
online i met with everybody through
skype or zoom
and then you had something soon then you
had some students that may have been
trapped on campus like they can't
necessarily go home or can't necessarily
return to their own countries so they
had to stay in the dorms and right we
hadn't
wasn't too pleasant either right oh we
had quarantined periods a couple of my
students actually they had to quarantine
at a hotel for 14 days without leaving
the room oh dear just to come to
university yeah oh my gosh it was very
hard
but
things are easing up a little bit we do
have tournaments now which is uh it's a
big plus right a lot of my students they
were norm hunting okay they were trying
to get that elusive grand master title
they had a whole schedule planned i'm
gonna get my first norm here my second
norm there and my next crack is going to
be there
that's all smashed away it's all
snatched away and they had to just be
patient and keep their skills sharp by
playing online
because well there were certainly no
norm tournaments right right so
a lot of them
they said i have to wait i'm gonna make
myself an online specialist for now but
it's just not the same exactly online
unlike over the board
over the board i can play you a
four-hour game oh it's gonna have it and
it's gonna be a cool game and i'm gonna
learn a lot i am not going to play you a
four-hour game online i i may play
41-minute games online but somehow
online chass is not conducive to
classical chess it's more blitz
it's the arena for blitz and rapid and i
think i get this asked a lot especially
by amateurs like why don't grandmasters
play classical chess online why don't
they it's boring
it's just straight up boring i mean if
you have a tournament and you're playing
for something of course you add to the
mix and we had several classical
tournaments online
during the pandemic but it doesn't have
that feel it's just weird when you're
not in front of the board i can't see
you i can't make you uncomfortable
right the clock is ticking
no trembling hand you know and somehow
when you're playing classical chess
online you have to sit in front of the
computer for 35 minutes waiting for your
opponent to make a move right
it's just like time's not passing right
and somehow when you're in front of the
board 35-minute thing by your opponent
passes in a snap it can't easily go
easily so it's just not conducive and i
think a lot of grand masters don't like
it and some of them just flat out refuse
exactly i i'm not interested at all in
classical chess but
online
but then it's the funny part the
opposite happens
when we are at over the board tournament
uh we we just had the rapid and blitz
which i really really enjoyed
but i'm even more looking forward to the
zinc fill cup which is a classical time
control where the players really
sit down and they carefully craft their
plans i have to say that i'm a huge fan
of rapid chess specifically i think it's
this wonderful mix of fast but also
something that can be explained to the
public we have time to go through the
games and explain their combinations and
their thought process and they still
have the time to calculate brilliancies
right but there is no substitute for
classical chess right it just has this
magic where you see these brilliant
preparations where you see that every
move needs to be precise and of course
the level of chess is so high now that
yes we do see a significant amount of
draws yes we do see a lot of games peter
out but that magic of this brilliant
classical chess it really can't
be explained and it cannot be replicated
in any other format right
for me i just have to say that i like
the grand chess tour a lot this hybrid
format this combination of blitz and
rapid in a in a contained tournament
then the classical the only thing to my
mind
that is missing about the grand chess
tour
we need more events we do need more
events that's it but they are coming we
do have more and more events planning
the grand chess tour and we've had so
many join now we have traditionally the
paris tournament i think that was such a
great addition to the tour and we're
gonna have so many coming up but i have
to agree with you the hybrid i love it
you have the best players in the world
not just in classical not just in rapid
and blitz you have to prove that you're
good at every format to be able to win
the gran chester and i think that's
what's made every tour winner so far
stand out absolutely
well thank you yasir absolutely again
dude let's go
we're in the park it's time to make a
hustle
oh
i know this one yeah i know this one
no
don't do it
oh
surprising me there
oh man i hate those hot cacitos
[Music]
i'm emily allred curator at the world
chess hall of fame
in august 2021 people around missouri
commemorated the state's bicentennial as
part of these celebrations a life-size
granite chess board will be installed at
a new park on adrian's island in
jefferson city missouri
surrounding the board will be 32 images
representing the contributions that
missourians have made in varied fields
including agriculture
music
literature
and sports
the board will also educate visitors
about significant historical moments and
personalities from the state's history
including president harry s truman dredd
and harriet scott's courageous efforts
to gain their freedom innovations of
george washington carver
the project was spearheaded by dr
jeannie karen sinkfield the co-founder
of the st louis chess campus
the chessboard is the eagle scout
project for andrew dowden a life scout
and student at helios catholic high
school in jefferson city missouri he
completed the engravings on the stone
surrounding the chessboard using an
epilogue laser at the scouts bsa
invention campus
around the board will be benches made
from 200 year old wood by life scout
maya thomas a student at kirksville high
school in kirksville missouri as a part
of her eagle scout project
on august 9th the efforts of both scouts
were honored during a ceremony
commemorating the dedication of the
bicentennial bridge which was attended
by governor mike parson lieutenant
governor mike kehoe and the mayor of
jefferson city kerry turgeon
a free brochure is available on site at
the world chess hall of fame
and for download at worldchesthof.org
it contains passages about the
historical moments memorialized on each
of the squares as well as information
about the efforts of the scouts who made
this project a reality
[Music]
welcome back to the fifth round of the
sing field cup we already have a result
for you guys as richard rapport did draw
with the black pieces very early on
against wesley so yes
for wesley as he explained came into the
game not necessarily thinking about the
sink filled cup or the gc2 tour although
i do think he was he said that he had
been uh drinking too much coffee didn't
have a good night's sleep and rather
apologetic about uh the performance
today you know those things
they really get you right but for me
he's securing victory in the grand chess
tour
clinching a hundred thousand dollars uh
bonus money i can't blame it if wesley
came into the studio and said i am
feeling like a million bucks today and
still thought
hey the wise thing here is to just force
the draw right it still makes a lot of
sense absolutely um i should point out
there was a thought i had when wesley
was here but i didn't mention it
but might as well confess now
you know commentators
tend to uh let's see uh
make up some stuff
so
speak for yourself never happened i'm
shocked so you know we're sitting here
saying oh wesley's doing this and
wesley's doing that wesley's he's
winning the tour it's a smart idea it's
strategic on his part and he walks in he
says
i just didn't sleep right now
it's hard to get inside the minds of
other people it's extremely extremely
difficult i get lectures on that stuff
uh it was just just just a point you
know you we we try to get inside their
heads and we get it right sometimes but
that time i think we got it
spectacularly wrong but we're still
saying we're right right yeah but still
how do you see the logic
you should you should have just said you
know you did it for the tour come on i
agree with us
like no no i was just a coffee i'm
embarrassed sorry about that yeah we
didn't expect that to come no who would
have guessed that was the response i i
i've heard a lot of explanations for
grand masters draws uh coffee blaming
the coffee hmm
that's not been
that that's a novelty for me
blaming the coffee yeah for me
not sleeping i'm not around totally
totally tons of players that have
trouble adjusting to jet lag trouble
adjusting that's me but no problem
coffee yeah we got the song blame it on
the alcohol
wow that i've actually heard isn't a
legit excuse a chess player drinking yes
it's shocking shocking to be sure uh
let's just turn our attention to the
game of shaq riyar for a moment because
that was really an intriguing moment
right here we had just seen the move
queen c2
um the engine actually likes rook c1
as a preparatory move oop excuse me
geez what did i do
let me get this there you go uh rook c1
the engine light is just developing a
piece and asking black what he's going
to do
queen c2 look far more logical wanting
to bring the rook to d1
after a very very long thought lanier
said you know what the knight has to
return to d4 and we were i for one most
especially was thinking oh well now
queen d2 i get the extra tempo of my
queen on d2 marie says the engine says
wrong yes sir put the queen back on d1
guess what shaq agreed and after knight
f5 however shaq
didn't go for the rook c1 move he went
for a more consistent move he
look he's gambited upon he wants to
bring his queen he wants to bring
everybody over to the king side he's
played queen f3 knight h4
queen
h3 and we had a variation where we had a
knight h4 and it was justified because
we're going to go knight back to g6 and
block the bishop on d3 knight h4 by
linear knight d5 bishop g3 knight g6
rook d1 bishop f6 we've all caught up
with the players and i would suspect
we're still in linear's preparation of
course he was caught off guard by the
move queen c2
clearly taking a long time after that
but he's played every move since
instantly which kind of indicates that
with the transposition knight before
queen d1 we're still in the analysis of
the
his preparation of his preparation right
and you know
actually and as even as white has done
all of these wonderful things he's
brought his queen over to the h3 square
he has developed his rook black still
has left his queen side pieces if you
will on the original squares
in a certain way black has solved a lot
of the problems he was facing uh before
specifically his queen on d8 was really
being targeted and now i
yeah i mean the compensation's still
there there's no question the
compensation is still there but i have
this real dread that by the time i win
back the pawn on d5 for example if i do
something as mundane as knight takes
pawn takes bishop here just terrible
ideas
if i end up winning the pawn on d5 guess
what
draw everything just to happen
all the pieces get traded so i think
lanier has righted his ship somewhat
with
the sequence over the last several moves
maurice back over to you question has
you guys ever studied the night's tour
the night yeah yes actually yeah i
haven't did did did you get a chance to
meet coltonoski by the way uh yes george
walton awesome yeah i did get a chance
to meet him
american yeah yeah george because that
was the knights tour that he did yes a
phenomenal memory he he also used to
play blindfold chess i think he held the
record before we have timor who holds
the record now
one of dorff
but anyway he was a great blindfold
player and he used to do the knights
tour and make money regaling people with
his stories as he did the tour which is
which involves a knight going to every
single square a single night with
nothing else on the board going to every
single square on the chess board once
from where it began and then the
mathematicians got involved and showed
the different night tours etc well we
had a night tour in this game
not quite not quite but let's start
right here this night here on b1
you're gonna watch it just watch tonight
we saw this game we're talking about the
game between maxime and darius knight to
d2 knight b6 h3 bishop h5 bishop b3 and
now let's get the second move of this
knight to e4 attacking this piece and
then a little intermezzo before knight
to g3 so much from here to here to here
to here
okay bishop f3
and f5 d4 by maxime f4 and the knight
goes back the other way
and
no no no no no
you remember that line that benny hill
anyway the nice back on knee too the
knight was here and he went here and
here and here and let's go back and
let's tour back to the d2 square that's
the same exact night
and this move
is the first move that alejandro said
no we didn't prepare that one that one
that one's different that was different
that's a koltanowski move
the kotonoski type knight back to d2 and
after he takes d4
now i'm not going to take a pawn i like
my knight on tour tonight his touring
with uh
jagger and his band well this knight
certainly has done a lot it looks like
it's going to take this bishop on the
next move
takes darus has now finally started
thinking like now he's down on the clock
clearly he didn't expect these moves he
can take on c3 in which case you could
take on b6 or you could just take back
on c3 saying i'll play this position as
well white has sacrificed upon
uh for this position he has compensation
in this bishop which is putting enormous
pressure on this diagonal and this
bishop is looking to potentially go to
the a3 square he does have some pressure
but it looks like black should be fine
here one of the moves the engine gives
is the very exotic
queen to g3
that's not a move you see every day
because obviously pawn takes
i can't do i can do there's a bishop
sitting on the b6 square so
this move is possible for black
what an interesting series of
possibilities chess is such a rich game
it's incredible thank you maurice but i
really have to help you because
i really have to share with the viewers
what uh the knights tour was all about
because what george koltanowski did was
something absolutely incredible i saw
him do it several times
um so there's uh a chalkboard if you
will at chessboard64 squares and he
would invite the audience as he's
regaling all the stories what would you
like to put on a a1 we're going to put
alejandro ramirez on a1 and
what would you like to put on e4 well i
like to put cincinnati ohio on e4 and
what would you like to put on f8
give me something anything a necktie
yeah necktie on f8 and what would he
sequence the squares no or what do you
do
random everybody just randomly
uh putting something on each square so
also all 64 squares are filled with
something a telephone number
wow okay now stop and think about that a
telephone number
a name a street address a a thing an
object
and then he would say to the audience
okay let's remove a square
let's remove the square like so we would
just
uh edge out f7 just that
so now he's got to go to 63 squares so
the he that the chalkboard would be
disappeared from his point of view and
he'd be talking a story and he'd say
well you know back in belgium in the day
in 1933 we had this incredible sequence
but before i do that i'm going to go
from cincinnati ohio to alejandro
ramirez and i'm going to go from
alejandra ramirez up to seattle on b3
and
by the time you get to the last seven
moves you can see
the path he's going to take and it's
just
it was all inspiring it was amazing
we've seen magnus we've seen magnus's
incredible memory right videos of that
too bad we don't have videos of what you
just described exactly it was just
breathtaking and it was so much fun i
mean and at the end everybody was just
big big smiles uh thrilled and delighted
us
and now who is thrilling and delighting
you with that position on the board is
jeffrey delighting you or is it fabby
well jeffrey had his own night tour in
this game as well
i guess he did because he had a knight
that was sitting
early
back here on f3 and we did see the game
i'm just gonna go through the moves very
quickly as we had this reverse grunfeld
castles and d4 cd4 knight d4 there's
that knight going on tour
e5 sorry got to move again and now a5
we're insisting says fabi
bishop to g5
a4 hitting the knight and now knight to
c1 that's a tour i'm
insane it's
not exactly the most exotic night you've
ever seen dropping all the way back to
c1 and after bishop e6 he chose the move
e4 we were thinking c4 in the style of
the grunfeld but he chose e4 and 5 he
said i'll take the space and now f4 and
5b said i'm ready you just weaken the e3
square
so if you take on e5 i'll just play
knight to g4 hitting this pawn
looking for the dark square bishop and
thanks for that great square that you
weakened when you played the move f4
right so bishop e7 now the night eight
still on tour bringing the knight back
out the engine does not approve of this
move knight to c6 played so far no
truly exotic moves in this game by black
except by this pawn we normally would
expect it to be back here but natural
squares for all blacks pieces while
white still has weird this bishop is bad
this night it's a good piece after all
that time though that it's spent getting
to that square and all black needs is
castles to say i got me a good game this
is great for black doing extremely well
and now bishop f3 stopping the knight
from going to g4 that's not a move you
want to play when you decide i really
actually have to play this move
something's gone wrong yeah what an ugly
movie that feels like absolutely it
feels artificial because of the knight
g4 problem had to be stopped though
because it was so powerful that's an
indicator that this tour
should have left him in seattle
[Laughter]
shouldn't have gone to alejandro a quick
question for you uh there maurice
because
it flashed through my mind instead of
the move bishop g2 f3
imagine i just
made the following challenge knight d2
knight b1 to d2 knight g4 not the not
the only move but a move i take on e7
i'm assuming queen takes for just a
moment and i was looking at f5 attacking
the bishop and the knight knight's got
to jump i'll take on
e6
take on d1
i take on f 7 with a hawk aceto
you moving your king and i'll take the
knight
do i have sufficient
uh compensation for the i got a rook
i'm gonna
i don't have an engine but i'm gonna
tell you the evaluation
no no no way knight c4 well let's just
continue i'm thinking i get to go
if you take on
f7 twice i was going to take on e5 and
oh hold on it's only two people it's
only two pieces you know you don't have
a rook on a piece you don't have a rook
on a piece two pieces i only got two
miners oh i hate when that happens right
no no no no not even close two miners
not a rook and a piece so those
variations will not work right i was
thinking that nah just didn't work
okay well well i asked and answered
isn't it wonderful and we do have
questions coming our way as we rejoin
the twitter conversation
let's see cinco cup can you please ask
the players if they feel playing in the
mask has some effect on their
performance that is a good question very
very good we have talked to them off air
most of the people that i've talked to
say it is annoying
but it is not to the point where it's
suffocating that it doesn't really
impact their performance too much but it
is certainly not comfortable definitely
not comfortable and for players who wear
glasses
i can tell you it affects
them because the glasses do at times fog
up and can you imagine yourself in time
trouble with little time on your clock
and suddenly you're breathing hard
through a mask and it impacts your your
eyesight so yeah i would i would say
it's uncomfortable maybe in some cases
especially so
but what are you gonna do i mean the
club unfortunately or fortunately has to
abide by the rules and regulations of
the city of of uh saint louis and for
this event you know we are practicing
all of the social distancing all the
rules and restrictions
even ourselves
we have a tape measure that confirms
that this is six feet of distance right
for that reason we have an exception
right all right we are told that we have
another tweet
uh coming this way
uh fourth street of the apocalypse
as gm's and commentators chess has been
a major part of your life for many years
what other aspects of your life outside
of chess have most improved or been
impacted positively because of what
chess has taught you for me it was
mathematics well thank you at ferret u
the fourth
ferret not secret the fourth ferret of
the apocalypse oh wow there was a chess
engine called ferret
from seattle actually it was pretty darn
good for me definitely life planning
seriously what i mean by that is
that
you have certain things that you have to
do
in america taxes very very important
preparing all your income taxes so you
have to take a very disciplined approach
to those types of things and for me
chess was a real discipline how about
you alejandro for me these questions are
always strange because i don't remember
life without chess it was always it was
always there so it's like asking you you
know when how did chess impact your
school studies that's okay i don't
understand the
always been there so for me
chess has always been an integral part
of my life
i know i don't feel that because of
chess i improved at something else or
another it would be difficult for me to
gauge uh the thing i do notice from a
lot of people and i'm glad that our
viewers said mathematics because that's
actually a rare one among grandmasters
it is
thought of that there is more of a myth
that chess players are good
mathematicians of course we have
exceptions we have extraordinary
mathematicians right dr john dr john
maxwell himself mvl
but
not necessarily because they study chess
but more because they dedicated
themselves to that field chess itself
not really being
yeah it's interesting the way you
described it because you were prodigy
very very young chess was a part of your
life i was a late bloomer i was 12 years
old so i really had a consciousness if
you will before chess so i kind of knew
what life was like without chess that
sounds terrible that sounds terrible and
then chess you know became a bigger part
uh maurice jump in how has chess
impacted other aspects of your life
chess has been incredible and late
bloomer you were 12 i was 14 right when
i really got into chess
and for me it was something that i
actually
consciously tried to get better at what
were the things that i could do growing
up in brooklyn
i didn't have the same or i didn't have
that many examples of top players to
hang out with and get better and i tried
every which technique i could including
thinking and studying other disciplines
which include philosophy
mathematics
self-help books as well and i think
because i was trying to get better at
chess
my extreme study of all those
other fields i say extreme study but my
interest in all those other fields
physics as well as to how to help me to
be a better chess thinker made me a
better thinker and person in life
and for me chess has been a method of
self-growth
beyond the chess board itself and i do a
lot of talks on that as well so chess
has impacted me in
profound ways
very much not one specific field i'd
like to take our attention to this
position right because shakriar
one thing about shaq you might argue
he's not exactly a subtle player
and you guys are laughing
and he's a man after my own heart
because i wouldn't consider myself
subtle either chakra would do well in
brooklyn hang out with the homies
because he lines some pieces up and is
like let's go it's going to be a war and
when the war starts you want that guy
because he's going to drop some heavy
bombs and he doesn't always play the
most precise endings but he knows how to
attack and so for me in this position
instinct said bring my bishop out the
way and go to b1 and let's rumble let's
just see what happens all the pieces are
ready all of white's pieces on great
squares the pin is on what are you
planning to do here now
the engine gives as best to move queen
to a5 a very interesting move getting
out of the pin and saying let's press on
you and get an attack counter attack
going and now a very profound move and
if shakira plays like this
he's a boss this move next move is very
tricky and it's bishop takes on g6
just because the queen just left you get
to centralize this knight get it out of
danger and now some just some trickery
some cookery started to develop in the
position you could take this pawn if you
want to sure suddenly the night is in
your house and things are slowly but
surely starting to develop is this
winning by no stretch but it's getting
dangerous uh this kind of position
building
i want to point out this variation
however bishop b1 queen a5 bishop takes
pawn takes knight to e4 bishop back to
e7 and here the engine gives g4 and says
white's a little worse so i tested it i
said okay i want to just play a3 tell me
why i'm worse and here the engine says
actually you're not necessarily worried
because we have to play the move queen
d8 if you've got to play queen d8 i'm
going to play like this i'm going to go
right into this line and test you
because there's it's not easy to deal
with this night on this knight coming to
g5 you play knight f6 the knight on e4
goes to g5 and we're in this tour mode
again these knights are dancing today
guys knight to g5 and here's a problem
because h7 is mate the knight could move
this knight is going to come under heavy
pressure f7 is potentially hanging as
well you've got to be careful if you are
black so yes black should be equal but
what
chakra is saying is you might be equal
i'm not trying to necessarily beat you
i'm just going to use some comp
let your time tick down let's get back
to the clock situation he's now at 32
minutes is linear the more you think the
more some trickery might show up a
little mistake here or there and you'll
get knocked off the board
the near deep in thought trying to
figure out what to do here i would argue
if you're black you probably want to be
practical somehow and trade some pieces
off but it's not so easy to do like how
do you make the next few moves as black
to lessen the pressure from your
position
well definitely go with your queen a5
uh looking as you say to trade the
pieces i definitely want to go knight
take c3 now for me the move bishop takes
g6 that's really confounding it's sort
of like you went bishop d3 to b1 you
could have started with bishop takes g6
you actually said no you i wanted to see
you move your queen to a5 first before i
give up the light square bishop that is
that is pretty peculiar another
peculiarity of the position is that if i
was black in that situation queen a5
bishop takes g6
i don't think i would be thrilled to
take with the h pawn i think i would be
thrilled to take with the f pawn because
it does come down to peace activity
right right
and in this particular case your rook on
f8 maybe your king is just a lot safer
lot safer when you think with the f-pawn
your rook is a little active on the
other hand the e6 pawn you know like
that's uh but you are performing
right i can say have that fun at some
point i'll have the pair of bishops
because you took on g6 right with your
own bishop i'll be happy to give that
one away finish my development and say
only black can be pressing interesting
uh interesting approach another game i'd
just like to turn our attention to is
feel i feel like this is a day of
questions you know and getting them
answers the answers are less than
satisfying i'd like to turn to the game
of peter svidler for a moment against
sam we're we're all you know applauding
sam for his wonderful effort of putting
his bishop on the long diagonal
protecting his king much more active
play and probably it's almost like the
last few moves right a5 okay that's a
purposeful move for white i
i understand you want to lock down uh
the queen side i'm on a good day you are
controlling after all this b6 square
then came the move rook c8 very good
rook
e4 protecting the pawn on e4 rook a4
protecting the pawn on e4 from afar
oftentimes rook takes c3 knight takes e4
very standard uh exchange sacrifice in
the sicilian i understand the move rook
a4
rookie 8 okay
h3 okay
queen e7 and bishop d4 and as i start
thinking about the last few moves and
you know like putting them all together
it's oh it's it feels to me like peter's
accomplished little incremental steps
and i i applaud uh his moves so much so
i started asking myself
what would sam
play after this move
and if i was to ask you
alejandro
and this position is black what moves
come
instantly to your mind as maurice often
gives us these flash tests uh would h5
have been first second third on your
radar i don't think it would have been
top ten
exactly that was because i was actually
having this exact thought myself like
what am i going to do is black am i
going to go rook c7
king h8 what what did i want to do sam
flashed out the move h5 and i was
confounded lots of questions for me
and i'm not sure
on the other hand i understand that move
you did play h3 as white
i get it to make lift and maybe to stop
the knight not necessarily because i was
gonna go g4 right but if you're gonna
give me the weakness on g3 perhaps at
some point i can start saying that i'm
gonna put my pawn all the way down on h4
and i don't know on a good day right you
put a knight on h5 or put a bishop on
this diagonal and that will be a good
day indeed right because like the pawn
on a5
looking to control b6 h5 h4 controlling
g3 um yeah well i'm waiting for the
forces to really do
uh a great battle but this seems to be
one of those games that
keeps
boiling boiling yes the temperature is
building now they also asked a question
what is white's next move right okay so
for me
my you know i'm thinking always in the
following terms
how do i improve my pieces what piece
is not at its maximum i kind of like the
knight on f4 or the bishop a lot of good
pieces to me even this bishop on e2 the
piece that i'm having the problem with
is my queen frankly i'm looking i'm not
now that i've said that i'm saying to
myself well what would be the great
square excellent show us maybe
maybe e3 maybe h4 so usually i would
play the move queen e1 to crawl around
the first to go to h4 queenie one played
yeah
uh but that but but when i played the
move queen e1 i was thinking i'm
dreaming that i could have provoked a
move like h5 because i i see that as a
i'm not going to say massive weakness or
something like that so sort of like it's
nice to see
maybe a weaker pawn on g6
we've been there were structures that
white could have forced where he would
go knight takes e6 f takes e6 maybe king
h
g6 is a little uh weaker your take on
our discussion maurice uh how how did
you evaluate h7h5 high on your radar
of moves candidate moves no i'm not
touching that pawn
okay that's what i wanted here
some old school brooklyn yeah
i need protection
keep it
solid age five week no that looks too
weakening no way in the world
interesting that's sam but sam has shown
some depth remember he came in and said
when we had that bishop on b6 that was
being buried by the move c4 c5 is black
and your bishop couldn't go anywhere and
said right so i said no but your knight
on b3 is worse than my bishop which
looks like b6
and we were
that was good that was very inside snap
evaluation i said that very insight
that's pretty cool there's a lot of
insightfulness let's dig down a little
bit in this position we talked about
queen the move queen a5 being met by the
very paradoxical trade bishop takes on
g6 the trade bishop for a knight is one
we call the grand master trade to give
up your lights to give up a bishop for a
knight takes careful thought because
you're giving away the two bishops when
you do so in a condition like this one
and
you have to make sure that your knights
will have great work and you'll be able
to attack the opposite color that is if
you give up a bishop this light square
bishop for this knight your opponent
will have a light square bishop that you
won't be able to compete against
directly anymore but you'll have a
knight which can control dark squares
that this bishop could never control so
you can use that knight to effect
on the opposite color of the bishop
bishop takes knight it's like one of
those grand master traits let's switch
to a different position and i don't know
if you're going to be happy here
alejandro why because i told you uh
there was some danger
a little bit not not serious but knight
c4 rook 81. now here
if you're arguing let's get the two
bishops advantage you take on the six
but
grabbing the two bishops here
not so special you can take back and
he's still got great solid position it's
it's playable to take and get a pawn
back uh if he trades
mvl said i'm not interested in the two
bishops i'm not thinking about the two
bishops that would be kind of stale
yeah old school thinking what i'm
talking about
is after rook 88
i'm going to take with on c6 give up my
bishop
and give away the advantage of the two
bishops and after it takes back
i'm going to now play
a quiet move bishop to d2
containing no real threat by the way
what did bishop like what's that
just developing a piece and saying your
turn your turn i don't want pawns back
you can take this pawn if you want to i
don't think you do because now this
bishop was quiet here turned into a
quiet assassin on this square with a
rook potentially coming to e7 that pawn
i could take any time i want to and now
white has tremendous compensation for
the pawn if black can even defend it
black will have to find some moves here
for example queen g3 that exotic move we
talked about before could be made by
rookie 7 also could be meant by just
takes before rook e7 now he'll take the
bishop and the bishops on the long
diagonal with some force so white
starting to develop a little bit of
initiative with this move bishop to d2
we saw how quickly darius played in the
opening now he's under an hour he's at
51 minutes and 48 seconds he's got to be
careful i said earlier i'm a little bit
worried for darius what happens
sometimes when you prepare and prepare
and prepare you're not in thinking mode
when your opponent finally forces you
into thinking mode you have to shift out
of your brain away from memory
into analysis and that transition can
sometimes take a little while to really
get
into the new the new position you're
facing as everything that you prepared
is now irrelevant because your opponent
is playing something different so let's
just be mindful he's got to play some
some good moves to the next i mean
obviously you got to play great moves
all the time right but i feel like the
next four moves four or five moves is
where this game's going to be decided if
he plays if he finds the right recipe he
can tamp down any initiative that mvo
has and get a nice game in rock and roll
but he's got to find those moves now i
feel like it's right that's my instinct
i don't know about you guys but i feel
like it's now that the solution has to
come
next few moves to say mvl it's nice yet
you played but i got this
well this is one of those position
where's where
precision is likely to account for a lot
and that's one of mvl's specialties yeah
so precise in so many this calculation
is just amazing it was actually very
surprising that yesterday
he didn't have that precision with the
move queen e8 instead of queen d7
yes
that lanier those chances it was that
one one mistake yeah it was gone it was
over after that one move mistake a quick
question for yourselves when you think
about the
um
table uh the material table rook is
worth five et cetera et cetera and you
you say the knight is worth three
what
what
count
material count do you get for your
bishop
if the knight is worth three yes i
usually like
it's
not a very
great answer but i would say like 3.2
3.3 and for you maurice uh
when you
do the
table the material
table
this is a complex subject for me i don't
really
believe in the table so much
i don't think it's a count that way i
just i think it's more the similarity of
the pieces
than it is the table count itself i say
a bishop and a knight are close and it
depends on the position i don't like to
say the knight is three the etc it's
just the pieces are close to each other
in value and sometimes the bishop is
good in this position and sometimes it's
even better and sometimes there's just
it's just about the same in value okay
so for me i always thought of the bishop
the night the rook five the queen nine
uh the knight three the pawn one the
bishop three and a half
so when you give up the bishop for the
night then that's to me what makes sense
because you're giving up a bishop which
has a higher
material value like in the game of shaq
bishop on b1 takes g6 right right so
you're giving up 3.5 because if i'm on
the sh if i'm an audience member in the
show and i'm hearing you maurice talking
as you just did mvl gave up the bishop
darius gives it gives up his bishop it's
like why why the bishop it only makes
sense if the bishop is more valued than
the night that you sit there and say
well i want to retain my bishop so when
you learned chess your table was
basically palms worth one bishops were
three knights worth three rooks worth
five queensworth nine yeah so i had this
argument three and a half for the bishop
yeah no no when you learned chess was it
also three and a half four
three three for the bishop i i in my
mind i
i made the bishop three and a half right
because the table was wrong and
i had this argument with grand master
christian carrillo one of um
yeah and uh he said something that was
so ridiculous that every grandmaster
like no you can't say that what did he
say
a queen is worth 10.
no you can't say that no but
i've heard you know the russians uh come
up with the queen is worth 10. yes yeah
i don't think that's a surprising
evaluation the queen
i mean a queen is worth nine like
does that
to me that again we start as beginners
with a certain set of numbers that are
agreed on that's what's told to us
then we freeze that in our minds right
that's what it is but then as you get
better you start saying
something's up here
there's so many exceptions absolutely
it's not absolute so then you start
making comparing contrasting situations
on the board
when should i give up a piece for
another piece sometimes you see a knight
that's a beast
remember uh
fisher played famously against taimano
knight takes bishop knight takes it
petrossian okay it's petros that's right
knight takes c7 and you're like that
night is a monster
that's nice not a night anymore like
some regular night it's a monster you're
giving up that for the bishop in this
position
everything is based on the situation on
the board and so we can't just do a
formulaic assessment of everything
sometimes we see an exchange sacrifice
but i got a knight in pawn and you go
i don't know what rook you've got but my
knights rocking and rolling and you
better sack for this night and you
understand that's what you should do so
i don't give the numbers any credence
i've known there's much more complex
mathematics done by folks to to make
this comparison about what the value of
the piece is i think when you start
looking for a specific value of the
piece the idea that a knight a pawn is
worth one and a knight is worth 3.6 so
the pawn is 1.00
okay got that a knight is worth three
point zero zero not three point zero two
no not three point one three not two
point eight nine i mean
it all depends on the position you look
at vichy for example
bishop takes knight all day every day he
loves his nights right so that's a
really complex topic the material
evaluation they've been booked not that
many books in fact written on the topic
and i think a lot of players are slaves
to that formula so when they see a move
like bishop takes knight by mvl by the
way i'm in a position
further down the line they're surprised
i want to get to this position though
i can't play a move i've been looking
for a move for black
other than taking on c3
i can't play one move that's not i have
not let's say can i have not played one
move that the computer doesn't say bad
you suck terrible i have not played one
move yet like i've tried different moves
i've tried competing for the e file i've
tried playing a move eight six i've
tried c5 every single move i made the
computer says that's not it that's not
it if this is it as far as the engine is
concerned about knight c5 that would be
my choice okay knight c5
computer thinks that's not bad you're
better than me all right knight to e5
would be the response and the knight has
given away the square
uh e5 so now
something similar but keeping the bishop
on b6 uh not blocking the bishops on b56
and the engine hates that move that was
one of the moves i tried as well
that's any good he hates that no now now
the engine wants
rookie set oh take it in rookie 7. no no
what no i can't take it i mean it's
crazy right so takes on b6 is is the
correct choice and take on d4 so you go
bishop c c5
you do have c5 the engine doesn't care
and i it's like it's sickening to watch
how this works but c5
the engine thinks is also not any good
and you're not going to believe the next
move
a4
is yours is your thing broken it must be
broken right
what are you going to do take right
because rook takes bishop c3 is not what
you want it's got to be broken
it's got to be broken it wants to play
rook c1
i mean this is outrageous this is
outrageous just break the structure down
and i mean this four against c5 is such
a spectacular move it's beyond it's
beyond our conception it's insane
nice will and vl find these moves
speaking of challenges by the way
shakriar has actually been in a deep
think
we left it right here and we were
expecting uh linear to come up with the
move queen a5 very logical move getting
off the d file as marie said you want to
make trades as black in this position
being pinned uh prevents that so what
did he do he moved his queen he said
queen b6 uh look at me uh i'm out of the
pin on the d fell i'm
hitting the pawn on b2 and asking
uh shaq what he wants to do now shaq
doubtlessly is thinking what i really
want to do is play a move like knight e4
and you know
bring everybody over to the king side
and
okay what's your next move queen takes
b2
and he did after a very long thing
play queen h5 did i see that yet next
time h5 queen h3 to h5
and he is once again offering the b2
pawn saying hey you brought your queen
to b6 if you want it you can have it
what is the point of the move queen h5 i
am not sure actually
so i'm thinking queen takes b2 maybe
it's just to move out of the attack of
the bishop on c8 so it makes makes sense
so that you can play knight takes d5 and
when it comes
you're here
oh
knight of snakes i was thinking about
knight f7 but i can't make it work rook
takes f7 bishop takes g6 pawn takes g6
rook e8 check rook f8 queen takes d5
check
give me your rook
you got to go bishop e6 no choice it was
not very good and now
well that's what shaq is thinking that
that's what how
not only that but we were trying to
understand why he moved his queen to d5
out of the way of the bishop on c8 and
this is
well we're we're trying we're searching
for the answer
here and we came up with knight f7
yeah
oh by the way we we don't necessarily
have to
take on g6 right away because knight f8
runs into a bit of a problem a puzzle
rush tactic
mate
so you have to still go back with the
rook
and i can take and i think you still
have to go with the bishop
i can take
and i haven't given up my bishop yet
with bishop takes g6 i like this for
white i do too yeah which probably means
queen b2
error
yeah
yeah wow fascinating queen h5 and
you know some
really really high level uh stuff going
on over here let's move to the game
between peter svidler and sam shanklin
that one
i'm not entirely sure
but it does seem like they might be
starting a repetition you can see that
knight on f4 attacking the queen on e6
currently not much to think about queen
e7 is really the only move if you put
the queen anywhere else it runs into
some kind of discovery exactly they are
repeating
should be a draw and i think that i
think for peter i mean these losses
have really uh and i think that's it i
think that's going to be the draw draw
agreed these losses that he's had in the
tournament have really uh
taken the wind out of his sails uh and
he's saying
enough rest day rest day
yeah let's just
recharge and and for sam
well i don't know how would you
evaluate his first half
certainly disappointed him big win but
he shacked did get that big win and i
think that's the difference between him
being completely disappointed with the
tournament and being
saying i'm okay i'm still fighting it's
not exactly where i wanted to be with
minus one but i'm back in the mix and i
think i draw here with black especially
against peter no problem for him okay
fair enough
and uh maurice back over to you because
uh dark i mean uh he's he's being
challenged by mvl yeah and mvl played
exactly that way
knight takes on b6 that we've seen and
now he's got another question to take on
the b6 square with which pawn looks a
pawn look natural but we saw that line i
want to point out the clock times
remember how big his lead was it was
like this well no no no he's starting to
time he's got 43 minutes to mvl's 34
minutes so now it's down to less than 10
minutes when we saw a huge differential
when he was blitzing out those opening
moves and already engine saying clear
advantage to white in this position
clear advantage so the idea is to do
this and takes and allow the c5 but i
mean this move a4 comes from outer space
as far as i'm concerned what an amazing
sequence a4 rook c1 prepare a5
that's chess that's some great chess if
nvl finds that he's a boss knight takes
on b6 some trouble here for
darius
slowly being outplayed by mvl
all right and
well i i just thought it was impossible
to keep the torrid pace of the last two
rounds uh i was a little bit
worried about the hubris of uh our
opening of the show to uh extol the
virtues of the many decisive games and
we have seen two
tame games i want to say just call it
what it is the commentator's curse yes
anything we say on air the opposite will
happen that's simply how the shows go
yes yep yep yep i think tom set it up
like that that's how it works
i am
quite honestly shocked that darius's
position is as bad according to the
engine
almost collapsing i don't want to say
collapsing that's too strong but it's
sort of like the pawn on f
the queen on h4 the pawn on f4
are you know two pieces all dressed up
with no place to go they're just stuck
on those squares the queen doesn't
that
there's no supporting there's no support
for the queen i want to say the knight
on f6
it's very strange it it does look like
that despite his extra pawn he's playing
material down and he's thinking with the
c pawn instead of taking with the a pawn
a6 a7 takes b6 far more natural how
about this
unnatural move maurice
this one is not looking good for him at
all he's saying after cd4 that he is
much worse like this one not sure is
definitely bad after this we are going
to see a rook land on e7 and how do you
want to capture you can capture with the
pawn of course and suddenly it's this
rook on the seventh rank the two against
one the weakness here this pawn looks
like it should be some kind of counter
play some should be valued at something
but and the bishop looks like it's
lording over the chessboard saying much
worse that this capture was bad it's a
bit
confounding to me but
white does have a powerful rook in the
position and a two to one uh advantage
on this side all right thank you for
that marisa again it's
it's so confounding right a7 takes
b6 which i think everybody's natural
move
and
a4 a4 would have just
that would have been insane right i kind
of understand i think darius's idea was
taking with the c pawn i don't think we
would see c takes d4 c5 i think that's
i would have taken with the a pawn if i
was going to do that i think 95 ideas
blocking the pawn okay
definitely a mental challenge but we
have a very special
guest in the studio aleandra of course
he's just drawn his game peter svidler
is here with us doubling his score
peter i
obviously couldn't avoid making mention
of the fact that you've had a difficult
tournament so far
to this point
draw today kind of stabilizes things a
little bit
tell us your thinking process coming
into today well i just wanted to play a
game of chess and like bishop d3 uh pe
is is not much but uh you know nobody
really has a clear idea what to do
against the neither of these days and uh
sem did not have any particular pry
experience against bishop d3 but he
played what i thought well like i didn't
prepare much but i took a look at the
file and it seemed to me that exactly
what he played is probably the sort of
the sanest and the the
uh
the the best way of replying and uh
true to form sam sam is generally well
prepared everywhere including lines
which
he you know by right shouldn't be
expecting on the day uh and yeah we got
this really strange position in which
not very much i think was happening at
any point but you know the one
interesting position we had is the one
in which he repeated moves i think
which is which is kind of curious and i
can see on your screen it says zeros
everywhere but it's it's very it's very
strange it's like starting from here
i don't really know what either of us
wants which is a very like it's a very
confusing position to play because it
seems like nothing much is happening but
i think it's slightly easier to play
with black because for instance like
rook c6 or qc8 as a way
not to create threads but maybe to
improve because not not much is going on
in the e file but maybe if you if you
double on the c file at some point
something will go to c4
and it's i think it's harder for me to
imagine where my pieces are going
uh and i was you know considering my my
track record in this tournament in in
situations where there's a complicated
position with not a lot of time on the
on the clock i was kind of worried
and honestly i missed something when i i
saw bishop d7 and i thought
there is this repetition which honestly
i don't think i'm better i don't think i
should be avoiding repetitions
and there's also the move queen of f8
which is what i was
going to discuss before guys before you
get to that
our panel was surprised by the move h5
were you i thought it's fine i thought
it's a very logical way to continue here
you don't really threaten h4 but you
know there's definitely some structures
in which uh the the idea of landing that
poland h4 much later on uh could be
could be an issue and in fact i wasn't
very happy about having to play h3 i was
i was choosing between h3 and king h1 in
that position when i when i played h3
because you kind of have to have
something as a reply to knight g4
eventually and it's either stopping it
all together with h3 or you prepare
bishop g1 as a reply it's one of one of
the two ways and
h3 was better in some tactical positions
but it also creates some potential dark
dark square issues and king schwann had
had other problems
yeah you had to calculate some things um
but yeah
going to going into the final position
we actually kind of had a slight
disagreement with with sam about that
because we spoke very briefly and he
said he i don't think i can continue but
after 95 instead of after takes takes
where he played queen e6 27 seemingly
without
uh you know too much too much doubt i
think queen of fate is a very
interesting option
uh and what i blundered well blunder is
maybe a strong word compared to some
other blunders i've made in this
tournament i i wanted to go rogue before
here
and if rook takes c2 i think i have a
very strong q in d1 move here because
rugby seven knight of three check is
very unclear
uh
i really don't want to give up that dark
square bishop i think it's incredibly
important for me to preserve the dark
square bishop here but i do have an
intermediary move queen d1 here
attacking the rook keeping my attack on
the b7s
pawn and also preserving exactly
protecting the default bishop for you
know eventual knight of three check
tactics and
this position i calculated and i thought
i'm you know not worse here at least and
then i realized that after rook b4 there
is a very sane kind of non non-forcing
move instead of rook takes c2 you can
play with c6 here
and in my mind i thought okay this
allows knight f6 check so it cannot be
good but i lose the evil pawn if i do
that and i don't think i have enough
compensation
uh despite winning the dark square
bishop the the knight on e5 just does
such a good job of blocking all of my
you know quote unquote dark star the
dark square initiative here that i don't
think i can do this at all
and i think of the bishop c6 sam said he
didn't think he could be better after
something like c3 but this is exactly
the structure i was going to to mention
like bishop d5 eg5 queen e7 or rook c7
rook c7 i don't know which one is
stronger
oh there's also 93 here which i did not
see but even if we talk about you know
the structural
assessment of this position
you go a five you double on the e file
and you start making progress on the
king side and this is like a very
classical you know happening in
heaven and i can't yeah i'm not in the
right mood for this
it's a kind of a running gag me trying
to pronounce heaven england correctly
but i
i can't do it right now i got a gargle
first
but yeah like i i feel like i'm obliged
to do it every time you know it comes up
but i'm just not in the right frame of
mind uh
so like i think bishop takes d5 is a
huge big threat there and
in view of that after bishop c6 i was
choosing between two positions i can
take on e5 and play bishop c4
or i can play actually i think i can
play bishop c4 straight away
so there's there's this position which i
couldn't really assess
or somewhat shockingly i think i can go
bishop c4 because after knight c4 bishop
g7
once again unless i've blundered
something spectacular which i've done
many a time in this event
queen g7 knight f6 is strong so you have
to take with the king
and i go roxy for bishop d5 quincy iii
check and i'm i think just in time to
recapture on d5 and i suspect i don't
lose this queen and rook
my king is definitely
the the unsafer one of the two but i
think there's
little enough on the board for me to
you know to be able to start threatening
some kind of c4 before c5 count to play
so that some sort of simplification and
draw probably results here
so that's one choice and the other one
as i said is to take on is to take on e5
and go bishop c4 which is quote unquote
more ambitious but could also be
incredibly bad if black manages to
stabilize because like currently i
appear to be exerting some pressure on
the f7 pawn but like what happens after
queen e8 let's say i don't know queen
eight queen queen g3 king h7 or
something like this yeah not blundering
any tactics and
you know my center could very easily
just collapse here and i could be in
tremendous amounts of trouble
so
my issue was i kind of blundered that
going in but after queen e1 bishop d7 i
don't think i have a particularly good
choice
so i tried making the move knight fd5
you know with that as confidence as
confident of a mug as possible
and kind of you know
invite sam to play queen e6 which he did
i once again i i can see i can see on
the screen that machine is not
particularly impressed about queen of
fade for whatever reason
uh but yeah for me
in particular the way the way this has
been going
uh
yeah i i kind of
liked seeing queen six there you were a
last-minute replacement for alexander
grishchuk as dariush was also a last
minute replacement in this tournament do
you feel like both of you have been
affected by that for
the same reasons you didn't know you
were going to play you had to jump in at
the last second you couldn't prepare for
the players it's not it's not really
that i i can't speak for darish but i
you know with me i think um
i i do like playing in like when i when
i told you before the tournament that i
like playing these fields i i'm not
lying but
uh it's incredibly important for me in
particular these days to start well
and uh
you know the combinations of it's kind
of weird in this tournament to complain
about pairings but starting with three
blacks out of the first four against
you know the the top the top
uh
three like the i'm playing the tour
participants so far you know
uh
not really playing i mean today was i
think my first game against the wild the
fellow wild card uh so a slightly a
slightly softer start or
specifically i think if i don't lose to
mvl like
my sort of general
state of mind is just so so much better
uh compared that um
possibly that would have made that would
have made some difference because uh
i i don't think it's even lack of
preparation i'm just uh
you know nowhere near playing uh
you know any you know my my best game is
not this hopefully you know i would i
would like to think that this is not
yeah i would like to think this is not
my a game and uh
yeah
the you know
the importance of a good start in a
tournament like this really for me from
i think for everybody but for me in
particular just cannot be overstated
it's just
it makes such a huge difference
you answer any questions no other than
peter enjoy your rest day recharge the
batteries and
give him hell in the second half
what are you trying to do for the rest
for a given definition of hell yeah
no no plans so far i don't know whatever
presents itself really you know
laundry is probably
very important but also you you you did
go elk watching yeah but i don't think i
don't think we're doing that again i
can't really force force alejandro to
although like forces may be a strong
work because it was enjoyable but you
know i like the else we had a good time
over there we did have a good time but
like we've we've done that the check
like there's there's already a checklist
yeah there's a few more things around st
louis i'll have to show you around you
know there's the we'll we'll see we'll
see what can be done yeah all right well
begin your rest now and then take
entirety of tomorrow to get ready for
the next day thank you
thank you peter
how was your uh
never mind i was going to ask how your
student was doing but we can come back
after yeah we're going to take a small
break here
and we will come back with the rest of
the action in round five just before the
rest day don't go anywhere we have three
more games of chess left in today's
round
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back we are here on the fifth
round of the sing field cup two results
already on the books
we have two draws petersville with the
white pieces drawing against sam
shanklin and of course we had the first
result of the day a very big one for the
standing especially the grand chess tour
wesley saw a drawing against a richer
report let's jump straight into the
action as we see what we have left for
you guys and i think the most exciting
game bar none will be the one between
geoffrey
young jeffrey who lost yesterday against
dario spheres he's playing world number
two fabiano carrana yasser how are we
doing there yeah well i mean i think
jeffrey actually has turned the game
around when we left it we left it around
these parts where bishop f3 kind of an
artificial move we really didn't like it
but on the other hand
um there was an issue in white's
position that issue was a weak g4 square
knight g4 knight e3 on black's agenda
jeffrey sought to stop that maneuver
with the move bishop f3 but after these
trades were executed it actually turns
out that well black just has a nice
advantage in space
and was actually much better now here
a rather controversial move for me was
the decision to play the move bishop e6
it's clear that fabi just wants to
castle and not suffer the consequences
of a lost pawn on f6 something like rook
a7 just simply defending the knight
preparing castles i think that's this is
just a nice comfortable advantage for
black that wasn't the choice oh bishop
e6 okay nothing uh the terrible or
anything like that then came this move
g5 well always always always i ask
myself where am i going to put my king
as black i play moves like b5 a4 i think
to myself well i'm probably not going to
go queenside i see moves like
g5 and i go well i'm am i sure i'm going
to go kingside
knight d8 that move i really didn't
understand knight came to
b4 and suddenly nice the knight is
looking and
yeah the knight is suddenly looking
towards the d5 square and by the way you
put a knight on d5
you open up the queen
to the b-pawn and rook b8
knight d5 well say hello
that knight is actually a monster
especially in terms of the f6 pawn and
the chances of an accident tactical
accident happening
castles
a whole mishmash of
strange decisions by fabi including up
to castles and h4
and i'm saying hey
jeffrey is taking over the game in a
very very big way in fact
i'm looking at this position i'm just
don't like anything that i've seen fabby
do in the last few minutes sorry the one
that baffles me the most bar none is
knight to d8 what is the right this move
i understand
you want to maybe reroute the knight at
some point put it on d6 that all sounds
great but i haven't castled yet right
the great knight tour and
that's a lot of moves too especially
because this knight on c6 is performing
an important function it's keeping that
knight on d3 at bay not allowing it to
go to b4 and subsequently d5 i don't
get the timing of this move knight d8
instead of
was there a problem with castling no
and if you were going to castle maybe
that was the time to do it after knight
d8 however
it also it also uh
precipitated the move rook b8 now when
you've opened up the half open c file
where does the rook belong certainly not
on the defensive square b8
knight comes to d5
castles move probably now made out of
necessity but now you look at this and
you go h4 oops so
you know you start rejecting lines oops
excuse me that start something like uh
h4 g4 f5 double question mark rook takes
f5 well this is child's play because
you've got the intermezzo queen takes g4
check and you can pick up your
sacrificed rook
and two pawns to the good so there's no
g4
you look at
g5 h4 you go knight h4 and now you're
you start averting your eyes because
we know the power of the knights on f5
on those kinds of nine hundred f5 and d5
posts up against the kids
no no no no that's that
so
that leaves
basically the only one move queen g4 and
you're just hoping that after queen g4
uh something doesn't go seriously wrong
for
black you actually play the move knight
f7 not queen g4 i think queen g4 even a
move like king g2 exactly dangerous yeah
no this but even here this looks
really like
okay something has gone
terribly terribly wrong how about the
simple knight h2 angling for knight g4
you know
putting the knight on f5 is good you
know what else would be really good on
the fi square how about a rook yeah
a rook looks yeah i think you start
having to play
potentially h5 this is ugly i mean i'm
just seeing
you know a lot of one-way traffic and
it's in white's favor
knight i'm not and i'm by no means is
knight h2 the only movie either you it
might just be that h3 takes g4 and some
very very direct play against black's
king
is like for example if you go tags
and if you go for example just throwing
this out there queen g4 uh first of all
pay attention to knight e7 check right
like where on earth are you going to put
your king you want to put it on g7 you
want to put it on the h file
you start
saying you know so it looks to us like
jeffrey all the way maurice all day all
day all the way we don't have to even
question our her instincts their
position what the heck did fabi do to
his position that one looks very
dangerous can the youngster deliver a
knockout punch though
take a look at this game and i want to
bring your attention to the time the
clock situation because it is ultra
dangerous for lanier right now
as
shakriar has managed to maintain the
pressure
move after move after move in this game
and with those two bishops particularly
the bishop on e5 just lording over the
board where it stands and the fact that
black hasn't figured out how to get his
bishop on c8 into the game we are now
at move 23 and the bishop on c8 did not
move finally
it has moved
finally got a chance to make a move
bishop to d7 yep pretty good move it
develops the bishop before
at last
yes as we have a very nice
image there of derek drinking is water
but okay bishop d7 the whole point is
you're not blundering a bishop rook
takes d7 queen takes b1 check returns a
favor but is there a follow-up to his
pressure that he's been applying maurice
i'm sorry i'm just checking is this just
equal or
what am i missing if you take on g7
right now
bishop king takes g7 and then i take on
g6
i like this
and then after hg and we need to try if
he picks up his bishop can i get my
bishop back but that's just a pawn no no
yeah
they just got my phone back right that
that was just a trade i meant so then
it's just equal after this and this is
dead drunk this is dead okay yeah all
right i just
flashed in my mind right like
yeah could you be winning it's the what
alternatives does
white have to this though because i am
one
move away from consolidating my position
even bishop a4 might be a threat
precisely so let's just imagine like
uh takes right takes queen so you're
what you're trying to say in all of this
is bishop takes g7 on the board by the
way bishop takes g7 on the board in this
type of play you're saying okay we're
playing bishops of opposite colors and
i'm putting all my eggs in the basket of
going h5h6 and you know dark square uh
maintenance dark square
but
you could lose you could go very
uh
with this attempt that was why we saw
the move bishop takes a g7
that one is on the board are wondering
you mentioned bishop a4 right sorry
maurice well i'm just saying after
bishop g7
i don't think linear overlooked this
move didn't either because
he didn't move yet i would think
well maybe just considering making sure
everything's okay that there's no
serious danger i would say zero other
moves in this position well i would say
that he is very aware that king takes g7
is
good enough for a draw he may just be
considering that's dangerous bishop gets
dangerous
because bishop is playable also bishop
d4 in case yeah bishop d4 bishop takes b
d one i can't get queen
b4 and i'm not i don't have to resign
but uh oh this is the line he's going
straight into it
which recovers his pawn
that he had sacrificed but at least to
an ending that we think should be just
fine for both sides exactly
exactly
well then we have to give lanier a great
deal of credit because
a lot of grand masters when they face an
all-out you know
firebrand raging uh
shaq riyar mamidarov don't survive
yep but this one
well into surviving territory i'm
telling you it was hubris on our part to
extol the the number of decisive games
we warned the producers if you don't
direct or don't do it don't do it
here we
are that was the time to do it because
after that
we know we get back to some kind of
normalcy here he could play the move
rook to e7 to try to keep a little
sliver of a game alive why not
plus pressure on the f7
for me f7 square queen f6 up next
right and black
do it well this i mean black's gonna be
able to put a rook on uh on f8 to
to defend
uh don't don't go pawn grabbing in this
case you will
be
defeated
i assume there are more than one ways to
defend against this right rookie seven
queen bee one czech looks okay
do you have a real thread by the way um
outside of queen f6 i
didn't see anything
too particular
h5 is a little annoying all right can i
play queen f5 and be professional about
it you will get yourself into a pawn
down rook and pawn ending i don't think
there's no reason
what rook does d2 is coming d2 is coming
i don't think i'm up on down here let's
just show this for the audience you take
on f5 i take back with the e pawn i
think
rook takes b7 and then after rogue d2
that forks both of uh white spawns on a2
and f2 and i don't see a way for you to
retain your extra no no no no i'm sorry
seven played rookie seven k7
the queen be one check and well
i'm not gonna just let that queen stay
posted so
powerfully on the f5 square
and there we see a little hesitation but
shaq has a very
intriguing weight and i i'm not used to
that
seeing
the grandmaster play and hold the piece
for count one count two count three
and now i'll let it go i mean i've
watched you for example playing here in
the club
numerous
you once you've made your decision you
know you're gonna play rookie seven it
happens you execute it that's it let's
go yeah but my medics
like really
hasn't been there right maurice how is
my student doing you don't want to know
you don't want to know but kudos to
maxime
because he got knocked out of first
place
and now he's coming right back i mean
just time to come back because nobody
else is winning their games fobby in big
trouble he might get knocked back right
yeah and nvl might take his place it
looks like a little rotating
leadership board except for one wesley
so it's like solid solid solid
this is a very good game bounce back
game for maxime take a look his bishop
we talked about the strong piece showing
its teeth but allowing knight d5 because
after all he gets this rook on the
seventh the rook went back to d8
rook to e1
and oh no c4 what a move
the point is completely unclear as to
why he decided to put that there i guess
he was threatening rook to d3
must be the only reason like why would
you play this move c4 and maxim said go
right ahead play that move and see what
happens to you because now this move is
met by
boom a nasty hit rook takes on a queen
takes on f4 you can't take this and
think you're going to survive because of
that check and anything else of course
queen takes will be the same thank you
very much as the rooks become monstrous
on the seventh you just gave away a pawn
and you're getting demolished rook e4
is simply a beasty move the c pawn is
about to drop the pawn you just put on
c4 is going to go off the board any
second you don't want to move your rook
away and stay passive because now that
your rook's off the line well why not
come into your house and these are not
rooks you want to see yourself fighting
against the security of the king you
mentioned this alejandro when you have
major peace endings like this the king
security matters and that pawn's sitting
on f4 right now
that one has weakened black's king while
white's king is sitting
very snugly on the g1 square
and b5
well okay that's that's his response he
is he is inviting a4
get played any quicker than that
i mean he's like next
known as quite the bullet player too i
mean that a4 move came
not with shaq
hesitation style but not at all uh
maurice if i if you don't mind me asking
alejandro and i were looking at this
position actually before we went on
break after knight d5 and i recommended
rook takes g7
instead of rook takes a7 and we were
looking at that briefly and it would
seem to us
that this was also advantage and black's
king is
pretty uh compromised yeah
you guys are correct according to
the engine here that
advantage white white because of the
compromised king
but yep yep this but was rook
g7
less of a move
a7 is better
that's what i would better okay sounds
just better just better
has drawn his game against linear
dominguez we did see that end game
coming from a mile away and everything
came off the board a draw here between
these two players a good result for
linear with the black pieces still up
there at the leader yeah i know this was
a great success
with the black piece as lanier
well tied for first and if he keeps up
this kind of form who's who's to say
that he can't win the syncfield cup
absolutely we talked about a wild card
winning
uh rapid and blitz the very first
time that a wild card here in st louis's
one magnus carlson was one a rabbit uh a
pardon rapping blitz that's a wild card
player in the zoo but no wild card has
ever come
remotely close to winning a sing field
cup or a classical
i want to say so this is impressive
stuff good work today
uh by a linear absolutely as he wraps up
a draw and this is a bad result for
chakriar yes because remember
where he came from this crazy what
gambit position yes maryse remember
wesley
wesley
looks like he's going to wrap this up
right right because he just has to
finish
no worse than third place
this is the standings we're looking at
right now chakra is
almost six points behind wesley he needs
to win this tournament basically because
wesley's not coming in like eighth place
now we know that's not going to happen
so chakra needs to somehow figure out a
way to win this tournament and have
wesley finish in fourth
or worse
and with this score right now
he's he's literally minus two or wesley
has two wins he's got to pick up the
pace to somehow
catch wesley pass wesley
fly by everybody else and prove that
he's the one who's going to win this
tournament with only four rounds
remaining but if we look at that stat
one more time all right let's assume
it's off the table wesley's gonna win
the grand chess tour there's a second
place finish that's that's worth
50 000
50k and look at his lead over maxine if
he says okay wesley's out the way i'm
not worried about him i've got a finish
ahead of this maxine vashi lagrav
character that's 50k on the table
right but
right now maxim if he wins he's going to
go back into the lead and maxine's going
to be like okay nobody's catching wesley
but hey dude
you're going to see the the the back of
my car all right i'm going to win the
50k income in second that point 5
matters and all chakra has to do is just
finish ahead of
adam maxime or even tied with maxime
this is all he needs it's a tie or a
head that's it little ahead if maxim
goes a little ahead of him it's over so
he was the winner in bucharest
doing really well felt really solid but
since then he's faded back i remember
maxime was was was maxim dead last in
bucharest
uh he tied for last time for last time
tied for a lot so you win and get 13. he
ties for last and gets 1.5 and since
then he's just been steven stevens
theming until it's like this and he's
about to overtake you and take the 50k
what a tale of a turnaround that would
be and let's not forget that despite the
fact that they're playing let's say for
second place there's somebody from the
outside saying hey i don't have a lot of
grand chester points but if i do really
well in this tournament maybe i can hope
for third or second place remember is
twenty-five thousand dollars sergeant
fabiano karana i wanna check out his
game how he is doing against jeffrey
shong we see a capture on g5 which in my
opinion was very surprising i liked the
3f's theory of maurice and i didn't
quite see why this was
forced
or fabulous right
uh we just left it at the move knight f7
i was more or less kind of drumming for
knight h2 exactly at this moment the
idea is to
leave this pesh key on the board that's
the weakness that i really want to focus
my attention on i want to go rook f5
knight g4 double rooks and really pound
that pawn for all it's worth maybe even
playing queen h5
if i could play also for example i'm
just going to put a very bad move on the
board queen h5 i might just sneak in
here
on g6 as well so when i saw this move by
jeffrey hghc i thought
wow you're really you're really letting
fabby off the hook a little bit that f6
bond
isn't as weak on g5 as it was on f6 and
opening the rook on a face right yep so
i wasn't happy about that trade but
jeffrey had a very concrete idea he just
wants to double up on the f line and
what couldn't you do without taking on
g5 though maybe but i mean that this is
pretty forceful stuff going on here was
it a good portion was it a good decision
glad you brought up the three f's uh is
it four so fantastic because if it's not
and that third f you don't want to know
this is not
ideal he still has the edge but he did
offer an extra possibility what does
this h-pawn do on h4
it guards the g5 square it guards that
square so that when this happens
and now the move rook f2 which he's
played black does have the option of
playing the move g4 knight h4 and
potentially knight g5 that gives him a
chance to bring his knight to one of
these squares now maybe he's evaluated
this and said i think i'm good here i
think i'm still great i maybe put my
rook on f5 and you're in trouble he
might actually be right actions now
looking looking at this this does look
like this is a weakness here
but if he had done it with just rook f2
sorry i am here i am here
rook f2 this is simply not a move i mean
no i was just losing this engine is even
giving killing blows uh like this one
whoa and this one and taking that and
smashing you completely so you just
don't even have that move that amazing
line
so that would have been pretty
straightforward but i think he's
assessing right here this is enough in
his opinion he's going to double and
what is fabi supposed to do about it as
he's just going to get what he wants but
if he had kept that tension you'd have
gotten even more but this still looks
strong it turns out
giving his opponent a little extra
opportunity but it looks like it is wide
for choice regardless uh neither
alejandro nor i like this trade on g5
how did the what was the number one look
after rook i mean immediately yeah
you the guy's helpless how could it how
did it how did it evaluate knight h2 by
the way with the idea of knight g4 rook
f5 it gives knight d6 i think it's not
one of the top moves knight
knight h2 he gives knight d6 guarding
god it looks so visually weird and
a little little pressure on this pawn
but it's still better for yeah this
still looks better
exactly without question but okay so
rook h2 it is and
for jeffrey i have to say starts with
three draws very very solid
plays an extraordinary game
almost saves the game epic at the end
man
you know how do you recover from a
loss like that
up against number two player in the
world and now he's playing fabulously
well
uh youth man
they're strong and they're resourceful
they snap back and maurice
so
we talk about this issue with
preparation you you cannot over rely on
preparation you know you're prepared
fine but know that your opponent is
going to play some strange move at some
point and then you want to keep in
rhythm you want to get out of memorized
mode i memorize these moves and i got to
get into play mode you want to somehow
be in play mode
even with your memorized moves somehow
get into a little bit of a flow so that
when that unusual move arrives it's
almost as though you've been
thinking through the reasons behind your
previous move and not just starting to
think for the first time as you turn off
memory and go into an analytic mode
this i'm making this point because up to
this point darish had been blitzing all
his moves he's sitting after 17 moves
with more time than he started with one
hour 33 minutes and 39 seconds he start
with an hour and a half
this move knight d2 was a move that he
wasn't familiar with and he continued to
play
13 moves he made from the point of queen
h4
and after a4
he's down to eight and a half minutes
ten moves to go
in what is a very bad position for him
so losing actually it's it's
very bad it's just everything is
collapsing he's going to lose one of
those queen side pawns and then he's
going to be a pass pawn plus his bad
king and he has no counter play
whatsoever the pawn on f4 is blocking
his counter play right against white's
king white's gonna leave it there unless
he's winning it
and winning the game at the same time so
this position is just dead lost
look at the clock times mvl was the one
who's thrown on his back foot he handled
the preparation marvelously with this
idea of knight d2 what an amazing
night's tour move if you will
and here he goes great position for him
we've seen we've we're going to be the
theme of this round if we have two
decisive results
call up george kozanowski or
email heaven or something all right
maybe he'll say nah he's the kind of guy
who's partying somewhere else but
look this night tour we talked about
this night on d2 started on b1 went to
d2 and toward the board e4 g3 went back
here and came back here and then c4 and
took we saw that whole path that this
knight took young jeffrey had his own
knight tour this knight on d5 was the
one that was on g1 right and he went to
f3 it went to d4 went to b3 went to c1
went to d3 went to b4 now sitting pretty
on d5
so if both these games are decisive it
will be the night two around for sure
with those knights
just dancing around the board fabian big
trouble with 13 minutes to make 12 moves
jeffrey's not that much ahead of him on
the clock though at 14 minutes but the
first time jeffrey is now ahead on the
clock and fabi knows this king is so
exposed
and white with beautiful squares for his
pieces
thank you maurice and i'm sitting here
looking at fabby's position more i look
at it the least the less i like it but
now having said that one of the things i
find really remarkable about our tour
participants is their extraordinary
resourcefulness
even under the greatest of pressure like
wesley
wesley defended that game against fabi
almost as if it was just like
right
every day and i thought it was a really
really hard slog like you hold that
position you're proud of your
uh
gifted defensive skills i'm looking at
this and i'm saying one of the things
that these guys do is they find
their opportunities to hold and i'm
looking at alejandro please help me out
here because i'm
i'm blind i'm
i'm seeing
rook f1 king g2 and
much much much worse things happening
for
fabi how do you
what's your defensive my instinct would
be to move the king to g7 okay i start
some sort of counter play on the h files
something along these lines hoping i'm
not losing you i assume you'll play rook
af1 i will of course and i was hoping to
get in queen
h3 very important because the desirable
rook h8 might just be met by some
immediate like sacrifices and the queen
will dominate over the two rooks in such
a position after knight takes d4 hence
your move queen h3 makes a lot of sense
but i was going to really i hope rock
your world with this move uh and simply
say
you know please open up your king you
know like do me a favor take this pawn
you just heard uh marie saying the pawn
on f4 was blocking
derek's attack the pawn on g3 is
blocking
white's attack against
the king so um
and i was hoping to go back
to
e6 i think because if i go to g for now
i was hoping for yeah this works this
was a tactic that would steal a pawn i
think it steals the game and steals the
game
okay okay real yeah nine to five check
and takes e2 no queen e2
95 96 oh no you're gonna make another
nightmare no no no no
e6 and 97 whatever you do
it's too pretty yeah yeah yeah beautiful
look at that
and the rooks
that's really pretty oh
that's a nice pattern
nice nice catch maurice oh that's really
nice by the way fabi has played a move
he did think he didn't play the maurice
move he didn't play our move he played
knight b6
okay after all this knight on d5
very powerful it is the crazy powerful
knight
so knight b6 oh
maurice you got some insights on this
move
the other game is going to be over soon
maxime is going to win rook d3 was
played now this was his point behind the
move c4 and boom queen takes he no doubt
i mean he must have seen right right
right right he must have seen queens you
cannot take because of rook to e8 we
know that he took with the queen rook
takes he now guarded the the square g7
because he knows rooks coming down plus
his rook is hanging as well and now
maxime took
and takes
no rook g8 is on the board he has not
taken yet yes he has he has he just took
right he just took it took and now we're
waiting to see c7 but rook to c7 and
he's threatening to just push
i mean that's
no i think you have to play rook b3 so
rook b3 will be forced and then he can
guard this pawn because you can't get it
back you just you're not going to be
able to play this move because of this
and the back ranked mate you're going to
find yourself down two pawns that's
right coupons in this position right
here looks like we have a frozen board
here okay no no let me go back to the
analysis to show what i was talking
about
uh
a takes b5 rook to c rook takes c3
by the way he could have just pushed
this guy
you get behind it and then you can just
push him again and prepare takes i mean
you can play c3 if you like he goes here
h6 and you play h6 and then he goes here
yep yep and you just cry that would have
been
a little easier that would have been
easier that's very straightforward very
straight he played very quickly with his
variation but he could just play b6 b7
and the game is over i think the game is
over it's over anyway after rook c7 yeah
no doubt but uh pawn could have just
gone down the board
step nevertheless he's going to capture
the second pawn
and
maintain his b-pawn
this game is done
no doubt about it great game by maxime
bouncing
dealing with opening prep
and playing like the all-star player
that he is yeah so you had mentioned
that you had seen few games in this
tournament that were just absolutely
perfect right and i'm going to throw
this one in there as well
i cannot imagine um
from being
hit in the opening with a series of
novelties and answering them in the
fashion he did he took he put his knight
on e4 knight e4 to
d2 very difficult move knight c4 knight
takes b6
a lot of
rook takes a7 instead of rook g67
right not even slightly
obvious maybe b6 right but that's what
are we talking about 35 right
at this point you're just choosing which
line to make him resign
right right exactly
wow something else dramatic is going on
in the game between jeffrey and fabi it
looks like fabi has played a horrible
mistake maybe a category of blunder
knight in this position we're saying
he's in trouble he's got to try to
defend he's decided to challenge the
knight on d5 with knight to b6 and check
out this move guys
knight h4
what
what a move
yeah what
so if i take the point is if you take
this rook f6 and there's a rook g6 and a
queen h5 knock knock your dead line
coming the queen has to give itself up
you're about to lose your queen and
there's no way to defend against this
check and that check straight forward
done game over so that means after
knight h4
you could you could try this move simple
capture recapture and uh if you capture
back here
knight f5 and suddenly there's this
threat that's big there's this queen
coming here there's that rook coming
here and there's that king that's gonna
die yeah
this game is done this is crush city
fabi in huge trouble if jeffrey finds
knight h4 right now what a brilliant
move that would be and the game is over
like over
that's the kind of move that you want to
play but
somehow
you start seeing ghosts
i wanted to put a knight on f5 i just
didn't know how to get there
knight h4 wow to be that tactically
alert at this point i mean after you see
this move knight b6 you start thinking
queen takes b5 which he has done by the
way he grabbed the pawn you start you
have his membership ready right
right
but
yeah knight h4
visually that's just an amazing
that's just a beautiful move if you
but queen takes b5 it's very hard if you
don't see that move not to take the pawn
so how does the line go here i assume
that knight d6 i attacked your queen and
hope that you have to go back
between d3 and i would
i have so many weaknesses around my king
i want i want to mistake
that
g5 g7
you're allowing me to do that right so
i'm happy sorry but you you had a maybe
you have to go queen g
no no no no no no no not queen g6
definitely not that move our viewers
would like to see why alejandro's
conception is a bad move don't don't
give me a royal fort don't go to g6 g6
is like the the taboo square you know a
landmine
no it still looks horrible still looks
good for
for jeffrey for sure no no sorry guys
queen e5 knight d6 black is back in the
game big time how what do you mean
queen d3
queen takes b5 knight d6 queen d3 yes uh
knight takes on d5 yes
and queen f6
queen f6
and you've got threats and gotta fight
four direct threats g4 and e4 threats in
this position your knight on f3 is
pinned cannot move
and and it's impossible to stop e4 so
just a second what does that mean i have
it means i have to go all the way back
to e2 a move i resisted i didn't want to
go with this far back
and after queen e2
our queenie
ii
black has
is even giving g4
which is now exotic it the evaluation
now is concrete black is no longer
even maybe
i don't believe that g4 okay well what
do you do okay
i guess i i move away 92 let's just see
id2 trade trade on f2 trade on f2 what
do you want to do queen takes f2 so he
takes f2 he takes your pawn for starters
uh knight takes e4 you mean
f4 he takes this one now black's better
right just that it's that simple now
black spin now black's better black is
playing for f8 knight e3
uh white doesn't have the event he
played the move knight takes d5 instead
that's the move that we have on the
board and jeffrey very quickly and to me
very surprisingly
took with the queen
because he did have the option after
queen oops excuse me you have to contact
chris takes d5 honking
these guys are in time pressure these
guys are in every time pressure and not
evaluating a position anymore
okay they're feeling the clock
and why was e takes d5 crushing
he takes d5 uh what do you do say queen
right
somewhere yeah
she's going to pick a move coming to the
party uh oh that's a queen g6 check
oversight
i was gonna
i was gonna take this pawn and take this
night but let me show
why this would fail epic wow yeah oops
rook h2 got me
incredible the pressure of the moment
they're just
exchanging mistakes
uh
just i'm sorry to be the message no no
no no but i mean but
these mistakes are very understandable
or very human moves if you don't see the
move knight h4 queen takes b5 grabbing
upon
it feels like solace personally by the
way another move i would have been very
attracted to was rook on a1
to f1 you know talk about a piece that
hasn't gotten into the game i i mean
like isn't it time to bring the rook on
a1 into the party
um so yeah some stuff
some strange moves there's a story that
was told to me by frederick friedel
who's the founder of chess base a german
company icon
is frederick fiedel
and he tells the story
that
gary caspar was playing in a tournament
i forget where
and he had he was watching the game with
what was now the new
fangled thing which was the in a new
engine right the computers are starting
to get strong enough so we're talking
about obviously the
20th century
before today before the 2000s
and frederick had this engine and he was
watching the game and there was a moment
in the game where the engine goes
gary's winning
and friedrich is like whoa
gary's winning
and
the move was a
funny-looking tight move
wasn't just obvious
and then gary didn't play the move the
game goes on there was some result maybe
gary wanted or drew i don't know what
happened in the i remember the point was
this he said he came to gary afterwards
and he said to him
you were just winning
at this point and gary went as soon as
he heard he was winning he went
that's the move
like just the fact that there was a
winning move sitting
now being alert to the fact alerted to
the fact that there is a winning move he
instantly knew what the move was he's
like oh don't tell me it's this and then
he went oh
and he knew it and that's when they said
they understood adjournments were dead
forever
right because this thing this engines
engines would change
the future of the game now for those who
are growing up with it engines just seem
like a normal thing they have radically
changed chess by their presence and this
if jeffrey had been told right here
after knight b6
you're winning right then he would have
said whoa what what wha what is wait a
minute i'm winning and he'd start
searching the board for ideas and no
doubt come up with the move knight h4
because he's been told he's winning now
so you're not looking for
some basic you're looking for the killer
kind of blow and what would that be it
would have to be something he would
figure out associated with this move
rook f6 because where else would you be
winning it's not me knight c7 and you
look around you don't see anything so he
would have found 94 because he doesn't
know that he's winning it's e that's
that's the thing
viewers sitting at home with their
engines on i'm here with an engine on
because that's my job in this in this uh
broadcast
the engine is telling us the move and
you go oh why don't you see that well
because
first of all the engine's telling you
second of all you're sitting at relax
we're not in the middle of a game
in front of a big audience playing for
thousands tens of thousands of dollars
is a pressure of the moment and you
don't know that you're winning you you
don't know without that knowledge you
don't necessarily see that move so
this is this is what happened to both of
them they're just playing on their own
with the clock ticking down a lot of
pressure on both at this moment in time
and four minutes four minutes left for
fabi to make ten moves and he's finally
traded on d5 and i think a little just a
little too much respect though from what
from
from jeffrey for fabi i think if i was
sitting across from the board
jeffrey would have been thinking i'm not
trading anything down i'm looking for
winning lines i'm trying to beat you but
he's giving fabi a huge chance now to
save the game
and uh fabi will take it thank you very
much while the rest of the field's like
come on jeffrey why don't you knock this
guy down out of first place absolutely
uh
just on that note also uh yesterday we
brought richard rapport in the position
and to to set and said okay richard
you're
here you missed a win and the moment he
heard the fact that i've got to win here
immediately sees queen a6 not even a
hesitation no yeah yeah of course of
course right all he needs is that you
know like just alert alert that's all it
takes right it really is a difference
yeah yep it's a difference maker no
question about it now that we've been
alerted well that's the two pawns
there's nothing to discuss there
uh
is going to win this game pawns up king
is weak
how is uh it gets worse like g6 hey g6
it's just just terrible now your king is
fully i said the king was weak
i didn't mean this week
this is just pure exposure right now
maxime knows this is going to be all she
wrote no question about it and he's only
got 41 seconds no they may move 40. oh
four move 40 has been made okay well
that was his move 4d yeah
adjust yeah sometimes it happens
underneath the pawns all and the pieces
there's some uh it's a heavy felt it's a
nice soft heavy felt but sometimes it
just frizzles a little bit and you get
these little you know like little
strings of linen and you just have to
take
take them out
it's bothersome i i can't explain it uh
the game of jeffrey and fabi it's
changing pretty dramatically i was about
to see
when we left it we saw the trade of
queens a b a b now remember how in the
game of mvl mvl uh broke up uh
derek's pawn structure by playing the
move a4 right well
he says hey you know what i'm trying to
draw the game let me play the move d3
break up the team over here and trey
pawns so that's what he has done with
the move d3 and if we do continue let's
just say takes rook takes we can see how
from fabi's point of view you know keep
trading off those pawns
uh his chances of saving the game really
go up i like
his decision do you see any problems for
black at this point after this well
let's say we start with this move uh
rook d1 so i'm
not even sure that helps you that much i
was hoping that that
that well yes that it helped me but also
that
i did have a threat of exploiting
um
the pin
so just to point it out to our audience
if you for example go rook takes d3
i'll go now it takes e5 and i do still
have
i cannot take the knight because there's
a rook on fade against the exploitation
i'd hoped for yes and if i go rogue g3
check after knight takes e5
that i move my king attacking the rook
exactly and uh
sorry i attacked the rook as well as
this knight on f7 so
rook takes b3 rook f1 you have to
respect knight g5 and knight e5 i'm
assuming you're moving the rook i think
rook d8 looks right like what it makes
more sense to me because you attacked
the d5 pawn
could've put the rook somewhere else but
i like rook the aid
okay so here
um
gosh i
let me attack your rook
i could consider taking on d3 i don't
actually know what's wrong with that i
think rook b7 94 might be a bit
unpleasant but
i'm trying to lure your your your pieces
to squares that i might be able to
exploit them here i'm not 100 sure
that's the case though
9496 i don't see how i can
you know really use the f file yeah it
looks in a meaningful way
um
so after rook d8 let me just try it
again
just another move how about knight h2
for some reason i've been
drawn for a long time like a long long
long time ago to this move knight h2
here i'm attacking the
the knight on f7 you can't well you can
go there but defending the night but why
walk into a potential check so i'm going
to give you guys a little pocket please
a little little prod okay in this
position white has a cool move right now
a move that is not winning but instead
it's a cool move yeah
it's got
it's got it's got some it's got some
teeth
you're not going to say rook a4 and rook
g4
no that's way too slow
right you're right
it's way too slow something rook a6 and
rookie no
rook a6
rook a6 threatening knight takes g5 and
rook g6 oh
that's a visual well it start it's just
threatening rook g6 and rook f6 and you
get the same doubling with your rook in
front and not giving you the chance of
moving your rook away
okay impressive that's a nice move
taking advantage of the open a file so
let's show it i take on d3 right rook
takes d3 this is what maurice is saying
rook check to the king king has to go to
h7 by the way let me just boldly point
out the obvious don't go to h8 and allow
meeting one or two two
king h7
and now
rook over ideas of rook takes f7
as well as knight takes e5 oh this is a
nine
nice one too i mean oops he's played it
rook a6
with the pressure on okay
is not happy looking at this one
i did not see rook a6 again that's kind
of like the poke you just got alerted to
opportunity absolutely and that's what
we've spoken about in cheating i mean i
know a lot of people in
the internet they all say oh these guys
use computers all they all they you know
like they play all of the first minutes
we don't need that no
no we don't even want that we just want
you know like hey you've got you've got
a combination right here like a red
light coming on and saying
do it right so how do we do defender as
maxine bachelor graph has won his game
against dario
great result there for unveil bouncing
back from his loss yesterday putting
himself
well in pole position because we don't
think fabi is going to win no probably
he's not going to win definitely
and with lanier's draw
yeah so let's go back to the game of
fabi fabi down to how many how much time
does he have he has four he had four
minutes when i last checked
uh yes
three minutes and 20 seconds so how do
we defend this
exactly so rook g6 check and rook f6
is a big deal those are real moves by
the way king g7 allows rook a7 precisely
g7 that is actually death yeah
i don't see how to defend after well
okay and
do your worst if he just drops back
maybe i just put a knight on e4
like it to 94 and i don't think you can
move
92 knight e4 and you don't think
there's a move
just
any knight moves will i'll knight f6
check
this
are we can ar are we absolutely
absolutely sure
no
[Laughter]
that's what good coaches do they tell
our students you know don't do this at
home um
though isn't it whether or not it it it
it looks like a strong result gate for
sure whether or not it's winning and
look at fabi he's done he had this
posture put his hands down brought the
hands back up but he doesn't have a lot
of time something's happening and he
needs to hurry because his clock is
ticking down and this move has reignited
the possibilities 1 54
how many how many six moves seven seven
he still has 34 to make seven moves left
and this move this is such a suspect he
didn't realize that this could happen
right and big time now he's gonna have
to find
all of his world number two skills
to save this position right because if
you look at the position and you just
see
three pawns versus two pawns yes yes yes
yes blacks on the back foot but then you
see this move rook a6 and you go oh my
gosh
this is really severe i mean at first
you think i'm so close that that that
draw i'm just going to trade some more
pawns rook a6 just changes
uh completely and he keeps he keeps
shifting his body you see this this is
that's the one
[Music]
he's going under a second
wow the tension power
clock he's just glanced at the clock
again he cannot focus properly on the
board because he's feeling the seconds
tick away he's literally feeling them
it's to his right in his peripheral
vision he's looking to make sure he
doesn't lose on time but it's hard to
focus when you're looking at variations
and seeing things that lose suddenly
start seeing ghosts
exactly
now again 37 seconds guys king g7 rook
a7 i can't do
anything to sacrifice it in exchange i'm
looking at
king jesus how much time does he have
his shoulders blocking there it is 25
and counting michael he needs a line he
needs some kind of saving move that is
such
it's so clear he doesn't see it i don't
know if he has one right but
if it exists it's not on his radar at
the moment no no he's real he's at ten
he's down to single digits he's
struggling his shoulder is blocking us
and finally he's played rook to d8 rook
d wait what if i don't wait five seconds
on f7 what what what
what if rook f7 i'm sorry what am i
missing f7 oh the rooks on a6
this move is a blunder yeah this move
loses
instantly i'm thinking of rook g6 check
yeah g6 king you have to go to h7 and
there is no choice whatsoever exactly
and then on rook have six
world cup 6 just wins right yep because
king g8 and now i take one f7 that was
my whole idea that was the whole idea
because
and then knight to d2 with a discover
check will pick up the road
think about it
that's it that's it that's something
that's a full piece yeah plenty of pawns
to play with still not even close to
simplifying those nope that's it
jefferson was going to have a huge you
you saw that demeanor yes you saw fabi
just just whew
he can't believe it this is this is
helplessness now this is the
possibilities and he's no longer focused
he just can't believe it he's
embarrassed for himself he was so close
and he couldn't figure out what to do
with
did he just define did he have a saving
grace he did
he did i will discuss it in a second
let's just let let's let him know why
because at this moment commentating
commentators curse where i said these 2
800 guys they find a way of saving
difficult positions this was a difficult
position gabby let his time go way down
didn't find the resource here he's
busted though two seconds one second and
there goes rook takes d3 and rook takes
f7 and he can resign
and has he lost he lost on five times he
lost on time
but it does not matter he was completely
busted
huge win for jeffrey
loses yesterday to dario spheres
three games
last rating of the tournament the lowest
rated to the to defeating the highest
rating wow
what a monster this kid is
incredibliest right
one day
you feel like just a terrible terrible
terror everything and the next day the
sun is shining
oh that is just a that is just really
really a remarkable turnaround extra big
big shout out to jeffrey as he says look
i'm going to be playing these u.s
championships in october don't think
fabby that you're going to have an easy
ride to the title easier ride what a
rocky roller coaster it's been four five
minutes
it's been a tough year and it's not
getting any easier he had a great start
here plus two score it seems like the
ship was back on its correct right and
suddenly he loses against jeffrey and
you got to be feeling for favi like what
is going on how do i get out of this
hole you got a second life by the way in
the game
because knight h4 was killing him the
first time that's right
he had a better position he let that go
then he was in a lost position he got a
second life and then
he lost it again right
bad game absolutely for him but somebody
who had a really great game
is now sitting with us one maxine
vashila grav bouncing back the way
jeffrey did yesterday had a loss maximum
he must have been tough yesterday
getting good sleep
this is exactly what the doctor ordered
though coming back today
well i mean i stepped
you know
i'm not influenced too marginally by
losses i
know that i need to sleep well so
but of course yesterday was a very tough
game in linear played extremely well
i
made a mistake you know from my
uh
not remembering my files and um
i mean like
you're insulting my coach by asking this
question
just until you know you're checking just
checking no insult intended
um but anyway today was also very tough
in the beginning because darius was
bleaching moves one after another
um but i had this feeling that i had
looked at all of this and you know i
couldn't remember his moves so like this
queen h4 for instance came as a surprise
but uh at least i could sort of remember
my moves and uh find over the board that
you know everything i was doing was
sensible
especially this 90 to 95 things so it's
the momentum of the game because
suddenly the position gets easier to
play for me and you know for
for a while it was not the case knight
d2 let's bring that on the board we said
today is the night's tour because
jeffrey's night i've seen zombies you
saw that as well flew around the board
your knight uh was on the start of the
game on b1 looking for a moment like it
was maybe headed back to b1 when you
played knight d2 of course it got to the
c4 square you just comfortably soccer
you gave your light square bishop back
gave back to your light square bishop i
should say and also sacrificed the pawn
what tell us why you assessed this so
easily as it would be good for you
um
well i knew it wouldn't be bad
for starters and you know the bishop and
basic suddenly like squares like like
zeus the pawn on f4
turns out to be a weakness in the end
and uh i got great control over not only
the e file
uh over the diagonal with the bishop
inevitably so that's why i thought uh
darya should have played dtex history uh
when he had the chance with the bishop
on c1 this i was almost certain let's go
back to that position you're saying uh
yeah
here i mean all d3 d3 was also
i was also looking out quite seriously
just oh boss with the ideas to enter my
bishop because once i get this bishop on
d2 and i do threaten to take on d4 it
suddenly gets very tough
uh
maxine if i may he played a kind of a
counter-intuitive move here c7 takes b6
what was your intentions uh once he
takes d4
c takes d4 c5 yeah and no queen takes f4
ah that's simple
queen takes f4 okay because another
pronunciation i mean there has to be a
reason for syntax b6 right
it was just an extraordinary thing right
here at this exact moment i'm sure queen
f4 is advantage for you the computer has
suggested the move a4 and we just
give away our grand master title
[Laughter]
you're laughing too thank goodness
you're laughing yeah
he's kind of moves
into our minds
if you had looked at this we were going
to ask the security to want you
once again
uh a4 is this a
very bad players move are two greats
yeah exactly one of the two but now
things were definitely going your way
here you've taken the pawn on a7 which
is excellent i could take on g7 but uh
then knight takes his three yes
and if hook g4 then my work is kind of
stuck on g4 like queen f6 will always
threaten h5 so uh i should take with the
pawn on c3 kmg7 context d4 contacts d4
and of course i'm better but i thought
you know it's much more difficult for
darius to play with
both my works coming to the seventh rank
and so on you made the right decision no
question about it
yeah and i thought he should play
something like hook d6 rook one h6 and
get his book to g6 but
it is ugly
right
something like this what you're just
that this was
in your view the way he had to struggle
or queen f6 i mean something like that
right right
but but of course it is pretty bad but
in the game
um
well
it's a bit unlucky of course that this
uh end game is totally lost after i mean
after you forward this frequent x4
because
it could happen that you get like this
b5 pawn but you you don't because of the
background mate so right
so a big company nice for you you're
back in first place
up and down down and up i mean i don't
count comebacks when it is one four two
one five so i will come to come back if
i i'm in first place after one night
okay well i was going to try to project
a little bit you get a rest day
uh to play that will be nice
lots of things to do
maybe some tennis or so and
some west you know
talking with my coach
having fun
with my
with my friends online
like
that i haven't seen for too long because
i've not been to friends for
for so long but
yeah
hanging out and
preparing mentally to be very focused
for the second half all right we'll let
you get to that preparation great great
comeback game
but we know you have more in you
congratulations thank you
congratulations emilia really really
nice stuff i mean i'd like it like it's
phenomenal no no i mean it's so hard
derek's preparation was so great
and to come back and win that kind of
game and our current standings uh
alejandra please it's three people at
the top but they keep changing now it's
wesley so linear dominguez and maxine
vasher legrav with three and a half
points it's actually fabiano karana that
is on the outside looking in he has
three points and it's jeffrey serging
he's reached fifty percent catching
shakira madeira and richard report
meanwhile sam samshankland stays on
minus one and dario spirits and peters
fiddler round off the tournament with
minus three as i i love watching these
uh top players leapfrog
leapfrog one another but we have a very
special young man in studio he has
defeated world number two fabiano
carrana we have with us jeffrey shong
jx in the building after a big comeback
win
jeffrey before we get to this game you
how's the field to lost to the lowest
rated player who's playing poorly and
then bounce back and be the number two
player on the planet
yeah um it is
it's a bit of a shock for me to be
honest because um i had a very bad
feeling after yesterday
and coming into the today to to be
honest i didn't have much uh ambition
so you know i just i didn't prepare too
much just played um
knight f3 g3 and see
what happens and uh
yeah i mean i feel very lucky because
especially considering how the opening
went i felt i didn't really
have any
i didn't really deserve to it to win
he did seem like he came after you all
guns blazing let's take a look on the
screen at this position when he played
the move a5
uh did you feel like okay the guy thinks
he's got to beat me even with the black
pieces
no i think he was actually just playing
uh what he thought was objectively best
i think the a5 a4 inclusion i feel like
is uh
is good for
black in general so
i tried to improvise with bishop g5
knight c1 but i think it's not a very
good idea
because
yeah in the game i think it's already
just worse for me
and yeah this position was supposed to
be not so great you had to play bishop
f3 that must have been not a move you
wanted to do
uh yeah bishop through knight g4 the the
good thing is um
it's a very bad bishop so i want to
trade it with bishop g4 so maybe it's
not
such a useless move
but yeah i think
the critical mistake from him was when
he played g5
because i think it just uh really wasn't
necessary and it created
kind of a hook for me later when i
played h4
but were you surprised by his decision
playing the move bishop e6 given your
given that he had this bishop
sort of good bishop that he didn't have
to give up yeah that's a fair point but
i think i i wasn't actually that
surprised yeah he can definitely keep
the bishops but like i said if instead
of g5 if he just castles i think it's a
very pleasant position for black he just
wants to um
play like rook c8 knight e7 and
eventually i'm gonna have to play very
passively to hold the c2 pawn
later
this knight of yours that went all the
way to c1 made this march all the way to
d5 that must have given you some comfort
when you put the knight on d5 were you
shocked by his choice of knight to d8
yeah yeah that i was definitely well not
at first i mean it made sense that he
wants to bring to d6 but when i saw
knight before was available then i was
wondering what he had uh
prepared there because yeah once the
knight lands on d5
it seems very dangerous for him
you then traded on g5 and in this moment
we had a possible move if you took on b5
here
but i'm going to prod you and say you
have a winning move right now were you
told before or do you
uh i i mean
my first instinct was probably knight
takes d4 but i couldn't make that one
work so
ah
that was my first instinct as well
jeffrey as it turns out
wow
that's very nice
yeah that's
that was the move uh that you you you've
missed
i i it's a gorgeous move uh we would
have had you we would have called
security on you
you could see moves like that right
and knight h4 was was winning on the
spot it turns out somehow you got
yourself to this position had
did did you realize how strong a move
rook a6 was not at first but yeah once i
mean
once i figured out rook af1 uh rook d8
was fine for him i needed to look for
something else right and uh
yeah i always have ideas of you know 92
94
but i think rook a6 is just a great um
inclusion because
like uh maybe the idea is to provoke
king g7 rook a7
he has to go king jay back and now
knight d2 is already very powerful that
was exactly what alejandro
thought as well that this would end up
freezing
uh you completely however we can back up
because there was something that that
you'd ask me the question that the
engine did spot after rook a6 and that
is rook takes d3
yeah we were discussing this line um so
rook g6 cage thunder f6
and then e4
yeah yeah i think he
he probably felt that this uh was
enough for a draw but under time
pressure he couldn't work it out so
i think we're saying uh rook f7
rook f7 knight g5
rook f7 check rook f7 knight g5
and then you might have to be precise
with where you put probably g7 makes the
most sense
g7 just to avoid uh because i don't
think i'd take with real quick
right so yeah once i take with a knight
there aren't any checks
and then yeah i guess you can just go e3
e3
wow
temporary sham
sacrifice of
peace
some nice nice things
jeffrey uh
congratulations seriously that was a
very very very big scalp
and
what are you going to do on your rest
day
i think the idea was to uh to watch
moneyball so i will watch that
maybe tonight maybe tomorrow but who
came up with that idea
uh it was yeah i
saw this movie was available on netflix
and then i wanted to find a good time to
watch it and i
made it i decided the best time was
maybe uh tonight so during the same
field cup makes sense
congratulations jeffrey huge result
there
what a shake-up in the standings
yes absolutely fantastic
really really good stuff and we've got a
second half uh such an eventful first
half
maybe well let's be fair
rounds three and four were so so
spectacular edge of our seat but this
round
pretty good not
would be satisfying i wanted to say mvl
the way he handled his business against
the great preparation of derek was
something to behold i thought that was
spectacular off the chart maurice please
another great round another great round
we saw some chess that wasn't really
fighting chess unfortunately wesley said
he didn't feel great so he didn't fight
out his game chakriar made a run of it
to try to win his for sure salmon and
peter they just couldn't quite figure
out how to get that going but these last
two games with the night tours
gotta love it gotta love it the
youngster taking down fabiano caruana
mvl making his comeback after a loss
still lots of excitement happening here
glad to have a rest day i'll tell you
that right but it's going to be good
going to round six as we still have not
separated the leaders i don't think
we've ever in the history of the
singapore cup
i can say this with certainty had three
players at plus two
going into the rest day but we did have
three players with plus two at the end
of the tournament let's see if they can
keep that one up of course we are on a
rest day tomorrow so
don't tune in but tune in the day after
as we return with round six of the
stingfield cup we'll be here to cover
all of the action thank you see you on
monday
over sunday
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited